vor ort für uns ist erhard scherfer sie
stehen erlegen ist draußen
das hat den grund dass diejenigen die
drinnen sind keine journalisten sein
dürfen
trotzdem wir wollen ein bisschen
sprechen von ihnen erfahren worum es
denn heute geht denn diese
veranstaltungen die soll ja noch einmal
ein bisschen dynamischer werden viele
haben kritisiert bei der ersten runde
dass er ein bisschen behäbig gewesen
muss man mal sehen zumindest hat sich
der ablauf leicht verändert das wird
beispielsweise nach einem eingangs
statement von paul zehn jahren im
gespräch mit der moderatorin die ja von
auch von der cdu engagiert worden ist
eine schnell fragerunde geben also drei
fragen jeweils an die drei kandidaten
die sie mit ja und nein beantworten oder
nein beantworten sollen die sie
allerdings auch begründen dürfen dann
noch und dann gibt es die in dem beitrag
schon angeklungen themenschwerpunkte
auch das wird dann in drei runden
passieren und da haben wir ja die themen
gerade schon in dem beitrag gesehen also
für jeden der drei kandidaten ein
spezialgebiet wenn man so viel dabei
klima und umwelt sozusagen für den
ehemaligen umweltminister röttgen innere
sicherheit friedrich merz und
deutschland beziehungsweise europa und
die welt passt ja eigentlich auch ganz
gut zu haben ihn laschet wenn man so
will und danach gibt's nochmal eine
schlussrunde wo alle drei noch mal sagen
dürfen was ihnen besonders am herzen
liegt und dann sind diese anderthalb
stunden auch wiederum es ist die zweite
öffentliche runde dieser art die die cdu
veranstaltet dazwischen gab es jede
menge veranstaltungen die den titel cdu
live getragen haben und da waren die
kandidaten verabredet mit mitgliedern
aus der partei und es war dann auch nur
für mitglieder der partei die sich da
digitalen 1 wählen konnten und dann auch
fragen stellen konnten den drei
kandidaten also ein verfahren das es in
dieser art noch nicht gegeben hat und
ich habe die gelegenheit gehabt vor
diesem gespräch hier mit sieben ja- zu
sprechen dem generalsekretär der cdu mit
dass sein fazit ist zu diesem verfahren
der kandidatenvorstellung herz im irak
seit mitte dezember ungefähr laufen die
vorstellungs veranstaltung es gab
unterschiedliche formate nächste woche
freitag beginnt der parteitag wie sieht
ihr zwischenfazit aus
es ist ein sehr positives zwischenfazit
es waren spannende diskussionen die wir
geführt hatten wir hatten
unterschiedliche formate mit den
einzelnen bewerbern mitglieder konnten
sich beteiligen und die diskussion haben
im netz stattgefunden wir haben gezeigt
dass wir diesen auswahlprozess
digitalisieren können es klappt auch in
corona zeiten dass man eine
demokratische entscheidung vorbereitet
und sich sein eigenes bild macht was
fanden sie besonders spannend dabei
besonders spannend und aufschlussreich
fand ich die debatte beim letzten mal
als alle drei kandidaten zusammen waren
an einem tisch und diskutiert haben man
hat gemerkt es ist eine sachliche
debatte es ist eine freundschaftliche
debatte und das gehört dazu denn die
partei steht zusammen nun faire und
sachliche debatten das eine und
sicherlich auch gut auf der anderen
seite so richtig wahlkampf atmosphäre
kommt dabei nicht auf wir leben jetzt in
einer zeit in der es vor allem um die
bekämpfung des corona virus es geht es
wird dann danach darum gehen welche
folgen müssten eigentlich wie angegangen
werden und deswegen sage ich volle
konzentration auf die bekämpfung der
aktuellen corona lage aber demokratie
muss auch funktionieren und deswegen tun
wir beides
was waren die reaktion aus der partei
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es da
gar keine kritik gegeben hat von den
mitgliedern beispielsweise an
veranstaltungen und an der form an in
dieser besetzung auch nein viele haben
eben das verständnis dafür dass wir
jetzt in der jetzigen situation nicht
hallenmieten können wie wir das schon
mal gemacht haben wo 56 7000 menschen
zusammenkommen das interesse wäre mit
sicherheit da gewesen aber jeder hat
nicht nur verständnis sondern wir haben
uns ja alle miteinander daran gewöhnt
dass digital heute so viel es geht und
möglich ist und wir haben das gezeigt
mit den einzelnen sogenannt cdu leafs
mitglieder können sich dazu schalten
waren zu sehen konnten ihre frage
stellen und mit anderen auch diskutieren
und das hat gut funktioniert hat auch
spaß gemacht ich habe ein parteitag am
freitag in einer woche also beginnt
schon mal angesprochen werden wir damals
noch mal den blick darauf richten das
sind drei kandidaten offiziell bekannt
gibt es irgendwelche signale dass es
möglicherweise noch mehr werden weil
formal wäre es ja möglich
formal wäre es möglich und so sieht es
auch das statut und die satzung vor
aber ich habe dafür keine anzeichen 0
ja ich habe keine anzeichen ich habe
jetzt auch nichts gehört dass irgendein
verband jemanden nominieren möchte ich
habe mich im vorfeld noch ein bisschen
beschäftigt mit dem mit dem verfahren
wenn es dann um die abstimmung geht das
wird ja auf der einen seite samstags
dann beim parteitag digital abgestimmt
es wird dann aber auch noch mal eine
briefwahl geben wie warum machen sie das
auf diese weise so wie vielleicht den
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern noch mal
erklären und wo sind da die
unwägbarkeiten was passiert
beispielsweise wenn die ergebnisse
unterschiedlich dann sind die ergebnisse
können nicht unterschiedlich sein weil
am ende steht nur derjenige auf dem
stimmzettel für die schriftliche
schlussabstimmung der vorher auch die
digitale vorentscheidung für sich
gewonnen hat deswegen steht dann nur
eine person auf diesem stimmzettel
anders als am anfang der digitalen
auslese wenn sie so wollen
von drei personen und wir machen das
weil es rechtlich nicht anders möglich
ist ich würde mir das voll digital
wünschen aber das sieht das gesetz vor
dass es bleibt definitiv auch am
kommenden samstag schon nur einer übrig
oder einer stichwahl muss doch
theoretisch auch noch möglich sagen die
stichwahl ist ja auch möglich es gibt
digital die möglichkeit erstmals
zwischen den drei kandidaten auszuwählen
erreicht einer der drei kandidaten die
absolute mehrheit dann hat er die
digitale fonds wahl für sich entschieden
gelingt das nicht dann treten die beiden
mit dem besten ergebnis gegen anderen
daran bei einer weiteren digitalen
stichwahl und wer dort die mehrheit der
stimmen auf sich vereinigen kann
der steht auf dem stimmzettel für die
schriftliche schlussabstimmung okay wir
haben schon angesprochen dass die
atmosphäre natürlich eine gänzlich
andere sein wird auch bei diesem
parteitag auch die reden werden
natürlich nicht von von applaus
begleitet sein zumindest nicht von
besonders großem was denken sie wie
diese wert sehr wird sich die allein die
form möglicherweise auch auf das
ergebnis auswirken
das kann ich nicht sagen ich kann nur
heute eins sagen es wird eine ganz
andere stimmung sein wir haben das alle
noch nie erlebt wir sind die erste
partei in deutschland die einen
volldigitalen parteitag durchführt mit
der wahl eines ganzen vorstandes und wir
haben alles dafür getan dass das ein
sehr gutes ein sehr guter parteitag wird
er wird maßstäbe setzen in der frage
digitaler parteiarbeit in modernen
zeiten aber gleichauf
ist nicht das gleiche wie ein präsenz
parteitag man ist nicht zusammen in
einem saal und ich freue mich auf wieder
auf die zeiten wo wir zusammen kommen
können sage ich ihnen ganz offen
haug ist inzwischen wieder drehen die
drei kandidaten sind auch da als letzter
ist von einer guten viertelstunde
norbert röttgen bekommen aber jetzt sind
offenbar alle parat wer wo sitzt ist
übrigens ausgelost worden wollte ich
auch noch loswerden und wir melden uns
nach der veranstaltung wieder dann von
drinnen übrigens dank eines kogit
negativen cupid 19 test und ich gehe
jetzt erstmal zurück zum michael krons
er hat vielen dank bis nachher
wir werden allerdings einen kleinen
augenblick noch brauchen die kandidaten
haben alle platz genommen
das ist und das muss man dazu sagen eine
veranstaltung der cdu auch eine
veranstaltung die von jemandem der von
der cdu ausgewählt worden ist moderiert
wird
also es ist auch nicht unser bild und
ich gebe nach berlin in die runde
guten abend meine damen und herren liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer und ganz
herzlich willkommen im foyer des
konrad-adenauer-hauses hier in
berlin-mitte ich bin tanja sadowski ich
freue mich sehr auf die zweite
kandidatin runde im rennen um den
parteivorsitz der cdu deutschlands auf
einen abend mit ihnen und natürlich mit
den drei bewerbern die sich schon warm
sitzen sozusagen im hintergrund und hier
im vordergrund mit mir der hausherr des
konrad-adenauer-hauses paul signac
generalsekretär der cdu deutschlands der
seinen job so gut macht dass alle drei
schon gesagt haben sie würden gerne mit
ihnen weiterarbeiten herzen lag und dass
sie das gut können das stellen sie
gerade unter beweis mit blick auf den
parteitag der ansteht das war glaube ich
ziemlich stressige wochen hatten sie
überhaupt zeit für weihnachten ruhe
zwischen den jahren
ja also erstmal guten abend und ein
frohes neues jahr
und natürlich ein die heute zu schauen
ich glaube wir sind alle froh dass
dieses jahr 2020 vorbei ist es war ein
sehr sehr schwieriges jahr aber wir
haben die privat wir bei uns zu hause
auch die weihnachtstage genossen ich
hoffe dass konnten alle auch unter
diesen umständen tun aber es waren
vielleicht gar nicht so freie tage
sondern freie stunden und wir haben dann
gleich weiter gearbeitet als team im
adenauer haus am 27 dezember um diesen
parteitag vorzubereiten denn es ist
tatsächlich eine premiere und es sind
arbeitsname wochen arbeitsame wochen
unter besonderen umständen sie müssen ja
auch sehr auf corona achten hast du hier
heute auch das ist so wir testen alle
die jetzt hier arbeiten jeden tag wir
haben eine ganz strenge hygiene konzept
übrigens bei dem bau unseres parteitag
studios niemand kommt ohne negativen
testergebnis in auf diese baustelle dort
wo wir alles vorbereiten und das ist
ganz ganz wichtig weil wir jetzt in
dieser zeit der pandemie zwei dinge
beachten erstens verantwortung
übernehmen dass niemand erkrankt dass
wir unseren beitrag leisten und
gleichzeitig sind wir handlungsfähig
auch in pandemischen zeit muss
demokratie funktionieren muss auch seine
wahl möglich sein und die ermöglichen
wir jetzt mit einer premiere mit dem
ersten vollen digitalen parteitag einer
partei in deutschland
ein wahlparteitag auch in sieben tagen
ist es soweit da wird ihr puls noch mal
nach oben gehen spannend ist es auf
jeden fall aber fühlen
was sie vor freude ja absolut ich fühle
jetzt vorfreude auf diesen parteitag ich
bin mal als generalsekretär denkt man
wie das ganze team was an was muss doch
gedacht werden was wo könnte es probleme
geben
wir wollen natürlich dass alles perfekt
auch technisch funktioniert und wir
einen guten parteitag haben
insofern bin ich sehr zuversichtlich wir
haben das hier sehr sehr gut vorbereitet
auch in der kürze der zeit und freue
mich aber auch nicht nur auf dem
parteitag sondern auf ein superwahljahr
2021 wir haben die landtagswahlen wir
haben kommunalwahlen wir beginnen in
baden württemberg und rheinland pfalz
dort haben wir zwei ganz ausgezeichnete
spitzenkandidaten mit susanne eisenmann
und christian baldauf und darauf freue
ich mich gemeinsam wahlkampf zu machen
stichwort superwahljahr haben sie selber
angesprochen die vielen landtagswahl
also der große batterie eine wahl ist am
16 januar aber dann kommen eben noch
viele andere
was ist da für sie besonders wichtig
außer der zusammenarbeit die sie
mitgestalten wollen da es geht darum
dass wir geschlossen sind als union das
kommt auf uns an
ich bin davon überzeugt dass es uns als
politische kraft der mitte braucht und
darum geht es wir sehen das auch
übrigens jetzt in anderen ländern was
passiert wenn die mitte auseinanderfällt
und ich bin davon überzeugt dass wir das
hinbekommen dass wir die richtigen
konzepte haben und dass wir alle
miteinander mit sehr viel engagement in
dieses superwahljahr gehen aber für mich
heißt vorbereiten des wahlkampfes nicht
jetzt schon wahlkampf zu machen denn wir
sind gewählt wir stellen die
bundesregierung wir übernehmen
verantwortung also wahlkampf planen ja
aber jetzt heißt es regieren und unserer
verantwortung sich bewusst sein jeden
tag dass andere überlasse ich der spd
jetzt heißt es regieren haben sie gesagt
und das heißt jetzt natürlich auch
gleich mit den kandidaten sprechen noch
eine persönliche frage herr merk ich
stelle mir dass ihre schwierig vor
neutral sie das gestalten das sieht man
eben auch daran dass alle drei sagen er
macht das toll mit dem werden wir weiter
zusammenarbeiten
aber trotzdem haben sie ja vielleicht
eine vorliebe wie können sie denn so
guten pokerface waren
ich bin ich kenne alle drei das habe ich
ja schon beim letzten mal gesagt sie
haben sie sind sie haben ihre klaren
position auch ihre konzepte für die
zukunft der union aber vor allem auch
für deutschland und sie haben alle drei
etwas was ganz wichtig ist für ein
politiker sie sind nicht nur glaubwürdig
sondern sie können menschen begeistern
menschen überzeugen sie treten ein und
sie hören zu und haben trotzdem ein
klares wertefundament und ich sage das
als ganz selbstbewusst als
generalsekretär der cdu
wir sind froh dass wir so eine auswahl
haben damit einen uns anderen das heißen
können auch mitgliederentscheidungen gut
leben das ist demokratie
und es geht darum dass wir auch nach dem
parteitag keine geschlossene partei sind
und da bin ich sehr zuversichtlich weil
das ist auch dna der union erst das land
dann die partei und wenn wir wissen es
braucht die partei auch um den land zu
dienen dann wissen wir dass unsere
aufgabe ist danke schön herr c max sie
wissen ganz genau was alles passiert am
parteitag damit sie liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer das auch wissen
insbesondere die cdu-mitglieder wird es
interessieren und nicht nur die sie
finden das programm und ganz viele infos
dazu unter cdu-parteitag in de da also
noch weitere infos noch mal herzlichen
dank hält sie mehr honoriert zu unseren
gästen bis gleich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja an diesem tisch haben wir schon mal
gesessen vielleicht haben sie liebe zu
schauen und zuschauer vor ungefähr drei
wochen gut drei wochen auch schon
zugeguckt bewährte runde andere
sitzordnung ich darf unsere gäste
vorstellen ich möchte eingangs noch
sagen wir haben gerade schon über poker
face gesprochen mit paul signac ich
finde sie drei geben auch eine prima
skatrunde ab aber dafür ist der tisch
ein bisschen groß oder das licht nicht
gemütlich genug wir bräuchten noch ein
paar hochschlagen machen sollen dass das
sehr spannend und um hilfe
das wäre toll es wäre mir eine große
freude also ich darf noch mal vorstellen
für den unwahrscheinlichen fall dass
jemand sie nicht kennt mir gegenüber
doktor norbert röttgen ehemals
bundesumweltminister und heute
vorsitzender des auswärtigen ausschusses
im deutschen bundestag und in der mitte
heute ist abend laschet
ministerpräsident des landes
nordrhein-westfalen mein heimatland und
damit auch vorsitzender des größten cdu
landesverbandes nordrhein westfalen dass
der landesverband so groß ist mag eine
ursache dafür sein dass sie gleich drei
nordrhein westfalen sitzen nämlich zu
meiner rechten friedrich merz er war mal
vorsitzender der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und ist heute
vize präsident des wirtschaftsrats der
cdu damit sie werte zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer wissen was sie erwartet
vielleicht schauen sie heute zum ersten
mal zu schiller ich ihnen noch kurz den
ablauf wie bei tatort und fußball
bewährt setzen wir auf 90 minuten und in
diesen 90 minuten geht es um die themen
ihrer parteibasis
besonders wichtig sind über 800
mitglieder haben fragen geschickt ins
konrad adenauer haus und teil als video
dass es besonders hübsch aber auch als
audiofile oder einfach schriftlich und
daraus hat dann ein redaktionsteam des
konrad-adenauer-hauses sechs
themenfelder destilliert drei dieser
themenfelder hatten wir in der ersten
runde schon bearbeitet da ging es um cdu
als volkspartei um soziale
marktwirtschaft und gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt und heute haben wir drei
weitere themen nämlich klima und umwelt
innere sicherheit und außen und
europapolitik ich glaube da ist für
jeden von ihnen etwas besonders schönes
dabei und werte zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer unsere kandidaten kennen die
fragen vorher nicht die antworten
spontan zum aufwärmen spielen wir etwas
ist es nicht doppelkopf vermehrt so
gerne ich das täte und es ist auch nicht
klar aber es ist so eine art ich bin
ganz schlecht im mission in din a5
format ist das noch mal schwerer
ja aber karten haben wir auch und wir
spielen jetzt eine art politisches speed
dating ich setze mal voraus niemand von
ihnen hat erfahrung in speed dating
jedenfalls nicht neuere erfahrung
ich lege wie karten gleich aus und jeder
von ihnen sieht dann abwechselnd eine
karte herr laschet wird anfangen und da
sind immer fragen auf die man ganz
leicht mit ja oder nein beantworten kann
aber das wäre natürlich langweilig und
sie haben dann jeweils noch mal 30
sekunden zeit zu begründen warum sie ein
ja oder ein nein wählen okay ich teile
mal aus wir noch mal jemand abheben sie
kennen das doppelkopf freigegeben der
stapel von höchster stelle
jetzt habe ich doch noch gemischt ich
soll sie können sich die ja auch zu
schießt dann ich hoffe so haben sie herr
röttgen langer arm dran
ok herr laschet wir sind sehr gespannt
auf die erste frage zeigt man ihnen und
herrn röttgen auch die kamera das wäre
dann diese und herr merz für sie ist
diese kamera zu stehen
nein diese diese entschuldigung haben
jetzt ihren kamera ist die und sie haben
30 sekunden bis die frage wohin wir
kennen sie eigentlich also die frage
lautet steuern erhöhen um die
schuldenbremse wieder einhalten zu
können
die antwort ist nein wir haben vor der
pandemie gelernt dass der staat ohne
steuereinnahmen jedes jahr mehr steuern
einnehmen kann
weil die wirtschaft gut läuft die
menschen in beschäftigung sind viele
einzahlen und damit die schwarzen nudeln
alles was wir bis 219 alten konnten
möglich war und deshalb nach der krise
müssen wir daran an
vielen dank herr merz zweite karte die
frage lautet gesetzliches recht auf home
office die antwort ist nein das brauchen
wir nicht das können die
betriebsparteien die
tarifvertragsparteien die unternehmen in
eigener verantwortung lösen
das brauchen wir nicht das können die
betroffenen besser selbst regeln ok
schlanke 14 sekunden vielen dank das spd
team so datenschutz zugunsten einer
effektiveren corona app reduzieren das
halte ich für falsch die krone ab app
setzt vertrauen voraus und darum braucht
es einen effektiven und wirksamen
datenschutz damit sie funktioniert sie
sind so schnell kleiner widerspruch
laschet ja ich glaube wenn es gelingen
könnte
wir haben das diskutiert unter dem
ministerpräsidenten wo auch grüne und
liberale sagen wir würden den schritt
gehen wenn dadurch andere grundrechts
einschränkungen zurückgenommen werden
könnten ist der datenschutz kein keine
unantastbare institution ist ein
grundrecht wie alle anderen auch und
wenn wir damit die pandemie besser
bekämpfen können würde ich sagen ja wir
können reduzieren schließe mich der
meinung ausdrücklich an
datenschutz ist nicht wichtiger als
gesundheitsschutz
wir müssen wissen woher die infektion
kommen und das wissen wir bis zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht und da könnte
eine krone app mit eingeschränktem
datenschutz helfen
mein argument ist ja aber nicht dass der
datenschutz wichtige satz der
gesundheitsschutz sondern ein argument
ist dass der gesundheitsschutz
durch die app vertrauen voraussetzt und
wenn wir den datenschutz reduzieren weil
wir sagen wir wollen das dann wird's
immer machen dann fürchte ich das
vertrauen verloren geht und darum einen
- für den gesundheitsschutz herauskommt
das ist meine kappe
ich finde schön das sind die spielregeln
etwas aufweichen wir haben auch etwas
zeit weil sie merke sehr schnell war das
war auch speed dating mit ihm
neben ernst also ich würde sagen ich
nehme an steuererhöhungen da haben sie
hätten sie alle das gleiche antwortet
aber wenn jemand da heftig widerspricht
das macht es ja spannend
wir sehen wo sie sich unterscheiden
vielleicht nicht bei allen neuen eine
ganze runde oft wenn sie sich auch einig
seien aber den dissens ist natürlich
interessant
herr laschet ihre zweite karte mehr
videoüberwachung auf öffentlichen
plätzen ein wichtiges thema wir haben
das in nordrhein westfalen an den
brennpunkten eingeführt da allerdings
ist unter strengen datenschutz
gesichtspunkten da ist er wichtig aber
wenn dadurch mehr sicherheit möglich ist
halte ich es nicht im ganzen land aber
an brennpunkten für hilfreich
okay ganz einig in der cdu im märz
deutschland ja für junge menschen
einführen ja auf der basis der
freiwilligkeit sowie die partei
vorsitzende annegret kramp karrenbauer
vorgeschlagen hat verpflichtend mache
ich ein fragezeichen dahinter das muss
man sorgfältig abwägen aber freiwillig
ja ok abschiebungen nach syrien
ich halte es für das kann man mit weder
mit ja oder nein kann man das nicht
beantworten das ist seriös nicht zu
beantworten
ich kann nur sagen wofür ich bin dafür
dass es keinen generellen abschiebestopp
mehr nach syrien gibt vielleicht ist das
auch gefragt also nein zu einem
generellen abschiebestopp für
flüchtlinge nach syrien für
terroristische gefährder jedenfalls nur
dafür wäre unser land an greift der hat
diese garantie nicht verdient der
integrationsminister
die nächste karte lockdown bis zum
sommer möglichst nicht wir müssen jetzt
alles tun damit die incidents werte
runter gehen deshalb haben wir im januar
war jetzt noch an einem maßnahmen
nachgelegt aber bis zum sommer wird das
land das nicht aushalten
und deshalb müssen wir schritt für
schritt insbesondere für kinder wieder
bildung kitas mehr ermöglichen als das
jetzt im januar möglich ist
und alles weitere hängt vom
infektionsgeschehen hat mehr
staatsbeteiligung an deutschen
unternehmen um sie vor ausländischen
übernahmen zu schützen
grundsätzlich nein trotzdem ist der
schutz vor ausländischen übernahmen
wichtig und notwendig und das kann man
auf anderem wege herbeiführen tempolimit
130 auf deutschen autobahnen
es ist dann ich sage nein zu den
generellen tempolimit aber es ist für
mich auch keine glaubens oder
überzeugungs frage aber es ist keine
forderung die ich aufstelle okay sagt
der frühere bundesumweltminister
sie wollen auch kein tempo 130 wer so
eine schöne schlagzeile okay dann haben
wir noch nicht ich glaube jetzt müssen
sie helfen oder wir sind durch die
reihenfolge war so interessant
danke dass sie mir helfen diesen abend
zu strukturieren auch das ist ja ganz
wichtig dass man führung zeigt danke gut
dann würde ich sagen starten wir mit dem
ersten themenblock klima und umwelt sie
wissen die berühmteste klimaaktivisten
der welt ist gerade 18 geworden
herzlichen glückwunsch an greta thunberg
an dieser stelle die cdu ist schon 75
aber klimawandel ist auch für sie ein
existenzielles thema schließlich gehört
die bewahrung der schöpfung zum
selbstverständnis der christdemokraten
die frage wachstum und umweltschutz wie
passt das zusammen bewegt ihre
parteibasis und auch was konkret hilft
gegen den klimawandel und wie sich etwa
die landwirtschaft nachhaltig aufstellen
kann dazu haben wir diverse fragen und
ich fange mal an mit albert ebert aus
hennef und herberts fragt denn der
aktuellen corona pandemie zeigt die
politik dass sie schnell und
entschlossen handeln kann und auf
argumente führender wissenschaftler hört
warum geschieht dies bisher nicht in
gleichem maß in der klimapolitik obwohl
die wissenschaft seit vielen jahren
belegt dass die menschen gemacht
erwärmung und der fortschreitende
verlust an biodiversität große gefahren
für unsere lebensgrundlagen sind herr
merz ivan basso entschuldigung in
verzeihung ich habe vergessen
da gibt es noch eine ergänzung das ist
ganz ähnlich deshalb weiß ich das noch
hinterher verzeihung nämlich das ist
karl werner götzinger aus köllertal und
der fragt was werden sie konkret dafür
tun dass die pariser klimaschutzziele
erreicht werden und damit auch das
wirtschaftliche wohlergehen unseres
landes gesichert und auch alle
diejenigen die die weitere fragen dazu
gestellt haben ich würde gerne zunächst
mal die feststellung treffen dass wir
doch schon im jahr 2021 sehr viel
erreicht haben wir haben uns
verpflichtet in verschiedenen abkommen
bis zum jahr 2020 40 prozent co2 ausstoß
zu reduzieren im verhältnis zum jahr
2000 1990 und das ist uns fast auf den
punkt genau genommen haben 36 prozent
minus in deutschland
und insofern ist es richtig zu sagen wir
sind auf einem guten weg aber die zweite
halbzeit wird die schwierigere wir
werden jetzt die anstrengungen deutlich
verstärken müssen
und weil die parallele zu corona gemacht
worden ist will ich aus meiner sicht
sagen ja wir müssen sehr viel mehr tun
aber wir müssen es versuchen mit
marktwirtschaft zu verbinden mit
marktwirtschaftlichen instrumenten und
ich widerspreche ausdrücklich alle denen
die sagen wir wollen jetzt mal versuchen
dasselbe was hier mit kroner gemacht
haben beim klimaschutz zu machen nämlich
mit erheblichen grundrechtseingriff
jungen um die erheblichen
einschränkungen auch des
wirtschaftlichen lebens das wird nicht
gelingen
das ziel ist unbestreitbar richtig wir
müssen sehr viel tun
wir haben einen wirklich massives
problem aber dieses problem sich zu
nähern geht nicht indem man das system
ab schafft sondern indem man im system
der marktwirtschaft mit guten
instrumenten anreize verschafft dass die
menschen sich klima gerecht verhalten
und da sind wir in deutschland schon auf
einem guten weg aber noch mal die zweite
halbzeit wird anstrengender
jetzt sagen sie gute instrumente was
finden sie gegangen der otis instrument
eines der wichtigsten instrumente ist ja
zum jahresbeginn auch zusätzlich weiter
in kraft getreten nämlich die bepreisung
von co2 ausstoß wir haben ja nun alles
schon gesehen dass das danken teurer
wird das ist eine beabsichtigte folge
also die preise auch so anzuheben dass
sukzessive das verhalten damit verändert
wird das betrifft auch die privaten
haushalte das sind die zwei großen
sektoren wo mehr getan werden muss der
verkehrssektor und die privaten
haushalte und die instrumente mit der
bepreisung von co2 sind richtig und auf
diesem weg müssen wir weitergehen
ok danke herr röttgen erwähnte ban ki
moon er früher un-generalsekretär sagt
deutschland solle mit gutem beispiel
voran genannt vermutlich haben sie als
früherer umweltminister damit kein
problem oder und wie weit geht voran
gehen also natürlich habe ich damit kein
problem jawohl wir müssen als die
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft dieser welt
als fortgeschrittene industrieland als
exportland den beweis erbringen dass der
alte konflikt den man immer so
dargestellt hat zwischen ökonomie und
ökologie zwischen wirtschaft und klima
in wahrheit nicht mehr besteht sondern
dass er aufgehoben ist das müssen wir
zeigen dass klimaschutz zu praktizieren
ein wirtschaftliches erfolgsmodell ist
das können wir zeigen es wird keinen
klimaschutz gegen die wirtschaft geben
aber ohne klimaschutz wird es dauerhaft
kein wirtschaftliches wachstum keine
industrie geben das müssen wir
zusammenbringen und ich finde die frage
aus hennef darauf darf ich ja und soll
ich ja auch eingehen ich finde sie
herausragt ja wir haben in deutschland
etwas bewirkt 40 prozent co2 reduzierung
im jahr 2020 das ist etwas aber
klimaschutz eine globale aufgabe und wir
sind global nicht auf kurs und wir haben
zwei prozent der co2 emissionen weltweit
in deutschland wir müssen mehr tun es
ist die große frage ob das zwei prozent
ziel überhaupt noch erreichbar ist es
ist die frage ob es überhaupt genug ist
das heißt wir müssen uns sputen
wir müssen mehr tun wir müssen es
erreichen und die frage war ja warum
gibt es nicht eine parallele zwischen
dieser pandemie und den klimaschutz das
war ja nicht die frage nach
grundrechtseingriffen sondern die frage
war die wissenschaft sagt es doch die
wissenschaft erklärt euch das phänomen
virus pandemie ihr habt sie beratend
hinzugezogen und auf dieser basis
entschieden und ich sage
so ist es genauso ist es dieses beispiel
auch wenn das virus ganz schnell ist
schnell zuschlägt und der klimawandel
langsam ist es ist die gleiche natur
gesetzliche unerbittlichkeit und wir
sollten die erfahrung die welt erfahrung
die lebenserfahrung jedes einzelnen fast
jedes einzelne mit dieser pandemie
nutzen und das beispiel übertragen in
die klimadebatte die wissenschaft
einbeziehen ehrlich mit den leuten reden
dass mehr notwendig ist als bislang
getan worden ist und die instrumente
vorschlagen die geeignet sind wirkliche
erfolge zu erreichen
und darum nehme ich das sehr dankbar an
und dann können wir diese instrumente
run wird okay vielen dank bevor ich
gleich weitermachen mit den fragen der
mitglieder noch der vollständigkeit
halber und aus interesse herr laschet an
sie natürlich die gleichen fragen aber
auch vielleicht mit dem fokus sie haben
ja ein zehn-punkte-programm schon
veröffentlicht und da spielt der
klimaschutz auch eine rolle vielleicht
kommt es dass damit ein fehlen in ihrer
antwort na ja klimaschutz ist ja immer
konkret die frage ist ja was machen wir
denn
und da hat die große koalition 2017 ich
habe das damals verhandelt das kapitel
energie gehabt wir haben die
wissenschaft zusammen gerufen aber nicht
nur die wissenschaft auch die
gewerkschaften auch die arbeitgeber auch
die energieversorger um zu sehen wie
steigen wir aus der kohle aus und das
beginnt jetzt die ersten
braunkohlekraftwerke sind vor wenigen
tagen abgeschaltet worden nachdem
fahnder bringt 60 prozent der
abschaltung von steinkohlekraftwerken
kann man alles in tonnen co2 reduzieren
und so wird das jahr für jahr
weitergehen
was ab nächstes jahr extrem ambitiös ist
weil dann auch die kernkraft endet und
irgendwo muss der bezahlbare und
verfügbare strom ja herkommen
also ist es nicht so dass die
wissenschaft uns eine einfache antwort
auf den tisch legt sondern wenn wir
stahlindustrie im land halten wollen
chemische industrie im land halten
wollen brauchen die strom wenn die
stahlindustrie abwandert nach china
und da den stahl produziert ist im
weltklima nicht gedient
ein stahlwerk in duisburg
ist ein beitrag zum weltklima weil es da
unter sozialen und ökologischen
bedingungen anders produziert als in
indien oder russland oder in china und
deshalb muss man abwägen was bedeutet
das für die industrielle substanz und
wie kriegen wir stück für stück dieses
ziel 2050 klimaneutral erreicht und da
kommt dann der nächste schritt hin zu
wasserstoff technologie die unternehmen
bei uns im land sind mit konkreten
angeboten bekommen hat norbert röttgen
recht die wollen auch mitmachen wolle
bayer andere die gesagt haben wir wollen
eine neue stahlproduktion nicht mehr mit
kohle und eisenerz sondern mit
wasserstoff grüner stahl
wenn das gelingt dann sind wir in der
tat vorreiter in der welt haben
modernisiert und arbeitsplätze im land
erhalten
ich will noch als in die runde werfen
weil das so wichtige aspekte sind das
eine vielleicht mal ganz konkret co2
preis sie haben es angesprochen wird
jetzt preist m ist das hoch genug oder
muss der höher werden nochmals mark
konkret na ja er ist jetzt jedenfalls
schon so hoch dass die menschen das
merken sie merken sie an der tankstelle
sie merken es bei ihren nebenkosten im
wohnbereich und trotzdem wird er weiter
steigen müssen einfach um dadurch auch
die modernisierung auszulösen und zu
verbessern
das ist auch nach dem
sachverständigenrat der ja für die
bundesregierung ein sondergutachten
gemacht hat zum thema klimaschutz der
richtige weg ich gehe so weit zu sagen
das ist der königsweg um das ziel zu
erreichen
es ist ein ein marktwirtschaftliches
instrument das den menschen einen anreiz
gibt ohne ständig mit verboten und
zusätzlicher regulierung zu arbeiten und
das ist ja der charme dieser instrumente
es verteuert den co2 ausstoß über einen
kurzen zeitraum und dadurch wird
modernisierung sinnvoll
danke herr röttgen co2 preis kann weiter
steigen muss weiter steigen
mit der ziehung der der emission von co2
einen preis zu geben ist das ganz
entscheidende marktwirtschaftliche
instrumente
ich war bundesumweltminister und
ich habe mir schon vor zehn jahren
darüber den mund fusselig geredet dass
wir es mit marktwirtschaftlichen
instrumenten machen wenn man der
co2-emission einen preis gibt dann
verursacht man kosten heute anstatt dass
wir es weiter so machen wie wir es seit
langem machen nämlich die kosten die
kosten die nächsten generationen
bezahlen zu lassen wir müssen die kosten
die durch klimaschädliches verhalten
entsteht in die heute zeit bringen indem
wir einen co2 preis gegeben dann
entstehen kosten und es entstehen
anreize für diejenigen die technologien
entwickeln um co2 emissionen zu
reduzieren
und darum ist auch diese gegnerschaft
glaube ich nicht mehr aktuell das ist
ein guter punkt ihn zu diskutieren wenn
wir immer sagen wir dürfen aber nur so
viel klimaschutz machen damit das
unternehmen nicht nach china ausweicht
vor unserer gesetzgebung dann ist das
immer noch in gedanken
der gegensatz dass das klima und der
klimaschutz die bedrohung von industrie
ist wenn wir in dem denken bleiben den
satz sage ich hier werden wir den
klimaschutz nicht erreichen den
klimawandel nicht stoppen
und wir werden die zukunft der industrie
unter wirtschaft aushöhlen weil dann
weil die lebensbedingungen des
wirtschaftens und der industrie dann
nicht mehr gewährleistet sind wir müssen
das aufheben und darum heißt es
natürlich auch dass es keine nationalen
lösungen
das ist ja klar wir können ja nicht nur
für deutschland klimaschutz politik
machen
es war ja auch nach dem pariser abkommen
gefragt also muss es auch europäische
geben damit wir einen fairen wettbewerb
in europa und das pariser klimaabkommen
ist ein un abkommen und darum musste
klimapolitik teil unserer handelspolitik
werden wir können es nicht akzeptieren
dass wir unsere beiträge blin erbringen
und china mit öko dumping auch mit
sozialdumping dann auf unserem markt
wettbewerb macht es muss also in die
handelspolitik aufgenommen werden dann
wird etwas draus sie haben gesagt sie
haben sich den mund fusselig geredet das
ist ja ein wichtiger aspekt bei diesem
thema dass man die leute mitnimmt und
das ist
oft gleichgesetzt wird verzicht und
umweltschutzes umweltschutz verzichten
auf dauer ist es eine modernisierungs
möglichkeit aber es so abzutun halte ich
auch für falsch unsere stahlindustrie
steht in einem wettbewerb und deshalb
müssen wir alles tun dass sie hier
bleiben und deshalb naja wird irland
hört dann na klar auch auffällt wenn du
die umwelt die auflagen immer weiter
hoch bringst und die anderen nicht in
der welt die du gerade so schön gemalt
hat wo man dann eine handelspolitik mit
china hinkriegt wenn sie das im moment
nicht machen musst du jetzt das
vereinbaren und es gibt unternehmen die
derzeit aus deutschland abwandern in
länder die schlechtere standards haben
und deshalb bleibt er ist richtig beides
miteinander zu verbinden
industriepolitik erhalt von
arbeitsplätzen sie bei der
modernisierung unterstützen ich habe ja
über klimaneutralität 250 gesprochen
über wasserstoff als an und anderes aber
nur zu sagen das wird sich schon im
rahmen des pariser klimaabkommens regeln
ist falsch es gibt den konflikt es gibt
im leben konflikte es gibt aber auch für
leute die vielleicht entspricht nicht so
locker mit seien auch konflikte auch
soziale fragen
ich finde es trotzdem richtig hat wer
mitverhandelt dass der preis steigt aber
das einfach aus seiner ecke ab zu tun
sondern kostet der sprit 20 cent mehr
ist zu einfach wir müssen die
gesellschaft zusammenhalten und der rest
der welt guckt auf deutschland ob uns
das als industrieland gelingt und wenn
es uns nicht gelingt wird keine uns
folgen und das muss man auch im blick
haben natürlich gibt es konflikte die
frage ist aber damals geschrieben
wir müssen diesen konflikt aufheben das
ist nämlich konzept soziale
marktwirtschaft früher war der mensch
der gegner des wirtschaftens wir haben
den menschen zu einem erfolgsfaktor des
wirtschaftens gemacht so müssen wir auf
die ökologie zu einem erfolgsfaktor der
marktwirtschaft machen das ist ja das
konzept ökologische soziale
marktwirtschaft integriert der mensch
und die umwelt in die marktwirtschaft
und darum ist geht es um die lösung
nicht herum dass die konflikte nicht
bestehen soll es geht um die lösung und
das was du schildert wird wird dadurch
aufgelöst dass wir sagen wir setzen uns
ziele natürlich fällt wird das nicht
alles dieses jahr stattfindet wird doch
nicht nächstes jahr
sondern wir brauchen klare ziele die wir
haben 2050 klimaneutral
dann brauchen wir klare schritte und die
müssen verlässlich sein dann finden
investition ist okay vielen dank machen
wir weiter mit bernward ilse der hat
jetzt ein ganz anderen aspekt
während weit ilse aus neuss und der hat
schriftlich gefragt der flächenverbrauch
in deutschland beträgt noch immer 60
hektar pro tag landschaften und
lebensräume werden zerschnitten flächen
für die produktion von nahrungsmitteln
zubetoniert und die artenvielfalt wird
weiter reduziert zukünftig werden mehr
flächen für den naturschutz gebaut
welche maßnahmen werden sie ergreifen um
den freiflächen verbrauch deutlich zu
reduzieren herr merz eine ganz konkrete
fragen also ich sag mal dazu ich komme
ja nun aus einer sehr ländlich geprägten
region und wenn ich bei mir aus meinem
büro aus dem fenster schaue dann schaue
ich in den arnsberger wald ein
naturschutzgebiet und sehe was dort
zurzeit mit der forstwirtschaft und mit
mit dem wald passiert wir müssen
zunächst einmal dafür sorgen dass
landwirtschaft und forstwirtschaft in
deutschland eine zukunft haben denn die
sind diejenigen die mit dazu beitragen
können das thema auch zu lösen
die flächen die wir dort haben die
müssen wir bewirtschaften das gilt
gerade auch für die holzwirtschaft das
ist ein ganz enorm wichtiger faktor für
klimaschutz und dann stehen wir in einem
gesellschaftlichen konflikt auch gerade
was das thema wohnen betrifft und was
das thema wohnraum für junge familien
betrifft und da werden wir gar nicht
drumherum kommen diese abwägung zu
treffen
ja wir müssen den landschaftsverbrauch
reduzieren auf der anderen seite werden
wir gar keine anderen möglichkeiten
haben wenn wir bezahlbaren wohnraum für
junge familien haben wollen auch
zusätzlich landschaft zu verbrauchen
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr in die höhe
zu bauen als in die fläche aber das sind
gesellschaftliche konflikte die müssen
wir lösen und dann muss es antworten
geben die beiden ansprüchen gerecht
werden zum einen dem wirklich dem
problem des landschaftsverbrauchs aber
auch auf der anderen seite für
gewerbegebiete und auch für wohnraum
brauchen wir flächen das ist nun einmal
in einem dicht besiedelten land mit 80
millionen einwohnern gar nicht
vermeidbar
ist der beiden und das ist wenn sie
sagen spagat ist oder oder kompromisse
machen zu müssen es ist eben genau die
aufgabe auch von politik hier abwägungen
zu treffen und auch zu lösungen zu
kommen und wir müssen eben beides
versuchen zu erreichen die landschaft zu
schützen und gleichzeitig wohnraum und
gewerbegebiete auch zu ermöglichen
jetzt reden sie sagen theoretisch ruhe
heller steht sie müsse also mal
ausfechten wahrscheinlich und thema
flächenverbrauch und nämlich ein ist was
auch immer auf ihrem schreibtisch landet
wenn abgewogen wird was gemacht den
wonach entscheiden sie das ist in der
tat ein dauerkampf die flächen reichen
nicht aus die landwirtschaft sagt wir
brauchen mehr flächen die städte sagen
wir brauchen wohnraum brauchen
gewerbegebiete und das muss man dann zu
einem ausgleich bringen das heißt man
muss in den städten sehen wo sind
brachen wo sind industrieflächen wo sind
versiegelte flächen die man wieder
nutzen kann ohne neu zu versiegeln
man muss in der tat auch
naturschutzflächen sichern das ist auch
wahr
aber man muss alle drei akteure
mindestens drei sind wahrscheinlich
sogar noch mehr landwirtschaft
städtische wünsche infrastruktur wünsche
miteinander in einklang bringen und das
findet im rahmen der normalen
landschaftsplanung landesgesetz planung
wo dann alle akteure mit am tisch sind
in einem ausgleich statt
aber es ist nur von und das ist auch nur
kommunikationsaufgabe herr röttgen wenn
man diese falsche interesse seien ja es
ist eine es ist eine
kommunikationsaufgabe ganz sicher aber
über einen konflikt in der sache der
besteht das sehe ich auch so
ich finde es aber auch schon ein
fortschritt wenn er als solche benannt
wird denn wir reden wie wir die ökologie
und umwelt debatte ist ganz stark und
auch mit guten gründen auf die
klimafrage fokussiert aber wir haben
auch ganz andere große andere fragen
nämlich artensterben der verlust von
artenvielfalt der unwiederbringlich ist
und der immer weiter voranschreitet der
etwas mit flächen zu tun hat auch die
artenvielfalt ist ein teil unserer
resilienz die wir starten müssen das
merken wir auch dass wir sie stärken
müssen und darum ist das ein sehr hohes
gut das auch eben nicht so nur gesehen
werden kann
dass da die frösche weiter quaken sollen
sondern artenvielfalt ist ein teil der
menschlichen residieren
unsere umgebung und darum müssen wir das
sehen ich glaube dass einer der ansätze
darin besteht dass wir den ländlichen
raum aufwerten
wir haben auch möglichkeiten das zu
machen auch als arbeitsort aufzuwerten
die digitalisierung bietet große chancen
dafür weil der ort der arbeit in den
digital und digitalisiert geprägten
bereichen ja fast schon unbedeutend wird
das kann ich von überall machen und
darum kann ich das auseinanderfallen von
arbeit und wohnen und leben besser
zusammenbringen denn dieses
auseinanderfallen ist auch eine ursache
für flächenverbrauch und darum die
aufwertung des ländlichen raumes mehr
tun für gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse
ist einer der ansätze um den
flächenverbrauch zu reduzieren ok vielen
dank wir machen weiter mit der frage von
jemandem der sich richtig auskennt weil
er praktika ist wilfried handys nämlich
und der hat uns ein video geschickt
ich bin wild and is ich bin seit 30
jahren mitglieder zu bieten
niedersachsens im ortsverein ilsede
ich bin landwirt landwirtschaft
bäuerliche landwirtschaft hat zurzeit
das problem dass sie zerrieben wird in
dem spannungsfeld zwischen auf der einen
seite großkonzernen die im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel einkaufen
dürfen und entsprechenden druck ausüben
auf der anderen seite politischer und
regulatorischer vorgaben im bereich
umwelt und auflagen die andere
berufskollegen in europa und der welt
nicht haben meine frage an die
kandidaten ist wie stellen sie sich vor
eine sich selbst tragende erwerbs
landwirtschaft mit den entsprechenden
maßnahmen stichwort zulassung von
pflanzenschutzmitteln gentechnik
sicherstellen vielen dank
ist das nächste beispiel wo man den
konflikt erkennt kann ich sagen dass
erhält auf dauer arbeitsplätze wenn wir
jetzt umweltschutz machen jede maßnahme
hat konsequenzen
und deshalb braucht die landwirtschaft
klare ziele wo wir hingehen in den
nächsten jahren und die jungen bauern
sagen mir ja was sollen wir hier noch
investieren wir wissen nicht wenn ihr
alle paar monate die regeln ändert und
wir investieren werden wir unsere
bäuerlichen betrieb nicht weiterführen
können das ist das eine
wo wir wirklich auch von der
europäischen ebene planungssicherheit
brauchen klare ziele co2 einsparung ja
aber mit der zusage planungssicherheit
und wenn wir die auflagen so hoch machen
dass immer mehr bäuerliche betriebe
schließen was wir zurzeit erleben dass
keiner mehr den hof übernimmt dann
kommen brauchen wir ja trotzdem noch
nahrungsmittel
die werden aber wieder importiert aus
ländern die sich an gar nichts halten
nicht an tierschutz nicht an ökologische
fragen und für die welt ist eigentlich
nichts gewonnen deshalb müssen wir
wieder im eigenen land zeigen mit guten
regeln bäuerliche landwirtschaft möglich
halten und trotzdem die ziele erreichen
dass der eine teil und der zweite ja wir
muten auch landwirt in dem moment der
menge zu beim beim düngen beispielsweise
mussten wir die auflagen verschärfen um
die regeln einzuhalten die wir uns
europäisch gesetzt haben das ist dann
schmerzvoll in der einzelentscheidung
und da muss man mit den bauern zusammen
lösungen finden wie übergangszeiten und
ähnliches geplant werden können die
agrarpolitik ist nun mal sehr stark von
brüssel geprägt und nicht nur national
deswegen wäre mein erster punkt zu sagen
die regeln die aus brüssel kommen müssen
wir umsetzen aber es reicht auch eins zu
eins und wir müssen nicht aus 100%
brüssel 150% deutschland machen der
zweite punkt ist die nachfragemacht des
handels ist ein dauerbrenner seit
jahrzehnten
dem muss man eine angebots macht der
produzenten entgegensetzen
rufe immer wieder dazu auf die
landwirtschaft sie müssen sich
zusammenschließen sie müssen auch dem
handel etwas entgegensetzen je
kleinteiliger die landwirtschaft ist je
größer ist ihre erpressbarkeit und der
dritte punkt ist wir kommen nicht umhin
und wir sehen ist ja jetzt auch in der
korona pandemie wir brauchen modernste
technologien auch im bereich der
biotechnologie wie im nacken jetzt
schmerzhaft dass uns die pharmazeutische
industrie in deutschland fehlt das holen
wir jetzt wieder etwas zurück ich rate
dringend dazu sich modernen
produktionsmethoden auch modernen
produktionsmitteln in der
agrarwirtschaft nicht zu verschließen
das wird ein teil der zukunft auch eine
landwirtschaft in deutschland sollten
also auch hier ist es wieder ein
beispiel dafür dass es konfliktlagen
gibt die andere parteien vor allen
dingen die grünen schärfen und ich sehe
die aufgabe der cdu darin die lösung
anzubieten wie man die konflikte aufhebt
denn ich bin davon überzeugt ganz sicher
landschaft und umweltschutz finden gegen
die landwirtschaft nicht statt aber die
landwirtschaft die die gesellschaftliche
akzeptanz verliert wird auch
wirtschaftlich keine zukunft haben also
sind wieder beide aufeinander angewiesen
man muss es zusammenbringen die grünen
machen das gegenteil sie hetzen
gegeneinander auf es gibt bei denen die
guten das sind die bio landwirte und es
gibt die bösen das sind die
traditionelle aber beide haben wir uns
ein problem die biolandwirte verbrauchen
viel mehr fläche viel mehr fläche sind
unproduktive sind teurer aber man muss
genau so sagen denn nitratgehalt in
unseren böden ist zu hoch den können wir
nicht weiter akzeptieren
ich glaube das konzept heißt
regenerative landwirtschaft dass sie
sind andere bewirtschaftungsmethoden das
ist ein über die jahres jahreszeit
hinweg betrieben ackerbau mit
unterschiedlichen fruchtfolgen das ist
der der die der natur bochum musste sich
an reichte anreichert die resilienz
steigt die artenvielfalt steigt das ist
dann auch eine gesellschaftliche aufgabe
ich plädiere für dieses modell aber ich
plädiere auch dafür wenn die
landwirtschaft
diese aufgabe übernimmt dann hat sie
auch die staatliche unterstützung
verdient wenn wir eine landwirtschaft
wollen die die umwelt schützt die aber
dann die umstellung auch von
produktionsmethoden beinhaltet dann
haben sie dafür auch verlässliche
unterstützung verdient und so kann man
die an scheinbar so die scheinbar so
gegensätzliche ziele glaube ich wieder
zusammen ganz herzlichen dank zum ende
der runde noch eine spontane schnell
aufgabe vieles klang sehr grün können
sie in einem satz sagen was ist das
wichtigste was sie von den grünen in
diesem punkt unterscheidet herr merz
einsatz also fällt mir deswegen schwer
weil ich unsere politik und das was wir
meinen nicht an den grünen messe aber
wir sind grundsätzlich eher auf der
freiheitlichen zweite unterwegs und sind
nicht der meinung dass wir die menschen
weder in der landwirtschaft noch auf der
verbraucherseite ständig bevormunden und
regulieren müssen grünen haben viel
bewegt weil sie dieses thema
vorangebracht haben was mir fehlt wenn
ja in einer täglichen auseinandersetzung
mit den grünen ist das gespür für die
soziale frage und das gespür für das
industrieland deutschland
man kann das versöhnlich aber sie
betonen dass falsche danke sehr
wir können etwas einzigartiges was die
grünen nicht können wir müssen
klimapolitische glaubwürdigkeit
zurückgewinnen
um der sache und um der jungen
wählerinnen willen und wir müssen das
dann verbinden mit marktwirtschaftlicher
kompetenz und technologieoffenheit die
kombination ist das cdu
alleinstellungsmerkmal muss es
jedenfalls werden
dankeschön für diese engagierte runde
hat spaß gemacht finde ich und die
zweite ist bestimmt auch engagiert ein
dauerbrenner für die cdu basis und nicht
nur für die innere sicherheit das ist
unser zweiter schwerpunkt vom berliner
breitscheidplatz über hanau und teile
bis zu den querdenkern unsere
freiheitlich demokratische grundordnung
ist aus mehreren richtungen
herausgefordert von menschen die sie in
frage stellen oder sogar mit gewalt
angreifen
wir sehen auch die organisierte
kriminalität nimmt zu
angriffe auf polizei und
sicherheitskräfte und cdu mitglieder
wollen von ihnen wissen wie kann der
staat die sicherheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger garantieren und auch wie sie
werte kandidaten die balance schaffen
zwischen sicherheit und freiheit und
dazu haben wir eingangs ein video von
ina und caroline schede guten tag ina
und caroline stadtverband reebok loco
nach dem mordanschlag von nizza warnt
generalbundesanwalt peter frank uns
davor die gefahr des islamistischen
terrorismus zu unterschätzen und unsere
frage lautet wie wollen sie diese
warnung ins politische handeln umsetzen
vielen dank märz na ja wir haben in den
letzten jahren wahrscheinlich manches
unterschätzt wir haben in deutschland
auch den terrorismus von rechts
unterschätzt
wir haben den terrorismus aus dem
politischen islam unterschätzt und wir
müssen uns mit allen mitteln die der
rechtsstaat dafür hergibt dagegen wehren
und wir müssen am anfang dagegen etwas
tun nicht erst dann wenn etwas passiert
ist das ist gilt für die terrornetze das
gilt für diese ganzen unappetitlichen
rechten szene für die linken übrigens
auch wenn ich nur mal an leipzig
connewitz denke das geht aber eben auch
für die sogenannten gefährder aus der
islamischen welt wobei ich hier gerne
unterscheiden und klar differenzieren
möchte zwischen denen die hier in
deutschland leben die hier vollkommen
integriert sind die sich korrekt
verhalten und denen die das nicht tun
das ist der kleinere teil
aber dieser kleinere teil ist das
größere problem und deswegen müssen wir
uns intensiv damit auseinandersetzen
wobei ich auch gern hinzufügen möchte
wir leben in einem rechtsstaat und wir
leben in einem land in dem wir uns auf
die polizei auf dem grenzschutz oder
jetzt die bundespolizei verlassen können
die machen ihre arbeit wirklich
hervorragend und wir leben auch in einer
weitgehend korruptionsfreien
gesellschaft wir haben ein
hervorragendes beamtentum in diesem
lande und deswegen ja wir haben probleme
die probleme sind lösbar
wir leben alles in allem in einem
wirklich sicheren und guten bleibt das
finde ich gehört in einer solchen
diskussion auch einmal gesagt bei allen
problemen die wir natürlich besprechen
müssen
vielen dank herr lacher wenn ich richtig
gelesen habe steht in ihrem zehn punkte
programm irgendwo auch die vokabel null
toleranz was heißt das übersetzt auf
extremismus speziell nach islamistischen
terrorismus
das war eine der hauptaufgaben die vor
mir lagen sich ministerpräsident wurde
in nordrhein westfalen hatten wir den
fall an die samui den attentäter vom
breitscheidplatz 13 identitäten quer
durch das land gereist vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet der einem v
mann gesagt hat ich will töten und
keiner greift ein kölner silvesternacht
viele andere fälle wo der staat
weggeschaut hat clans im ruhrgebiet gibt
es seit 30 jahren oder in berlin
wir haben gewusst da ist irgendwas aber
als herbert reul unser innenminister die
arbeit aufgenommen hat hat er überhaupt
erstmal ein lagebild erstellen lassen
damit man weiß um wen geht es und wie
gehen wir dagegen vor
und insofern war da unser prinzip wir
werden nicht mehr dulden rechtsbruch in
jeglicher form und die frage kann man
einen gefährder abschieben ist eine
juristisch extrem komplizierte frage
weil er hat ja noch nichts gemacht es
gibt aber die möglichkeit in unserem
recht und wir haben seither zweistellig
gefährder abgeschoben die im land waren
das verstehen wir unter null toleranz
liberal weltoffen sein
multikulturell in unserer lebensform
aber bei denen die sich nicht an die
regeln halten das auch durchsetzen
und ich glaube das war der kern auf der
frage und das können wir eigentlich auch
nur europäisch die attentäter von paris
lebten in brüssel
also muss auch europäisch das wissen
über gefährder ausgetauscht werden damit
wir wirklich diese geißel die wir
überall im moment erleben in ihre
schranken verweisen und weitere
terroranschläge verhindert
sie haben geschworen von liberalität bei
autorität des rechts dass
da ganz gute oder absolut autorität des
rechts und die beiden fragestellerin
haben ja ganz präzise gefragt aus anlass
der anschläge in nizza nach dem
islamistischen terrorismus
man hätte auch noch paris nennen können
man hätte auch noch dresden nennen
können und man hätte auch noch wie
nennen können
wir haben hunderte von islamistischen
gefährdern in unserem land und die frage
ist berechtigt was tun wir schützt der
staat kann er schützen was sind seine
instrumente ich habe ja in der politik
als rechtspolitiker angefangen aber mich
aus dieser perspektive des rechts des
rechtsstaates damit beschäftigt und bin
jetzt seit jahren ihr vorsitzender des
auswärtigen ausschusses meine erste
antwort dazu ist dies zeigte
islamistische terrorismus dass wir die
fragen und wichtige fragen der inneren
sicherheit diesen terrorismus
organisierte kriminalität
kleinkriminalität nicht mehr nur noch
verstehen können wenn wir auch verstehen
was in der welt los ist denn das hängt
unmittelbar zusammen dass wir intern im
staat die instrumente schaffen und sie
dann auch anwenden das ist ja sowieso
klar aber wir gehen wir vor allen dingen
mit den gefährdern um die ja noch nicht
die straftat begangen haben und hier ist
meine aussage ganz klar ich bin für mehr
abschiebung
das mag das ist eine eine grenzfrage des
rechtsstaates weil sie ja noch nicht die
tat gemacht haben
die gefährder sondern sie sind
identifiziert als solche von denen ist
zu erwarten ist ich finde es nicht
liberal
wenn wir sagen wir warten so lange bis
das verbrechen begangen ist bis der
anschlag gemacht ist und dann handelt
der staat sondern derjenige der von den
verfassungsschutz und
sicherheitsbehörden als islamistische
terrorist erfasst ist der gehört
abgeschoben und ich sage es hier
nochmals war eben ja in einer ganz
großen frage
darum war der generellen abschiebestopp
auch der abschiebestopp nach nach syrien
auch für islamistische gefährder und
terroristen falsch und es ist gut dass
der ausgelaufen ist da haben wir eine
meinungsverschiedenheit aber ich halte
der ministerpräsident einer regierung
hat mich dafür sehr kritisiert auch
andere mit geringer aber wenn dann ist
auch er hat mich nur gefragt wie machst
du es denn wie bringst du denn jemand
zurück nach syrien
das war die frage das sind ja die kann
ich auch beantworten aber die erste
frage ist starten wir den gefährde den
terroristischen gefährder in unserem
land mit der garantie aus du wirst
jedenfalls nicht abgeschoben
und darum ging es nur dass wir diese
garantie nehmen und ich halte es für
einen ausdruck unseres rechtsstaates der
autorität des rechts dass wir das dass
wir das nicht tun und das zweite ist
habe ich eben wie man sich das nicht
studieren das ist dann das ist erstens
ein signal des rechtsstaates du hast
diese garantie ist ja noch da nein das
ist aber dass das ist eine frage der
autorität des rechtsstaates ob wir den
terroristische gefährder sagen du
bleibst jedenfalls hier
und wenn wenn wir ihn haben ist es eine
einzelfall entscheidung und es gibt
möglichkeiten nach syrien abzuschieben
in den norden in den nördlichen teil
nach syrien und von diesen möglichkeiten
wenn es rechtlich im einzelfall geht da
liegt die hürde nicht ihn da
hinzubringen in die nördlichen teile des
landes wird er da hin zurück geführt und
diese möglichkeit besteht und die sollte
der staat sich nicht nehmen lassen ein
zweiter punkt noch weil der absichtliche
sparkurs der habeck hat uns aufgefordert
es muss mehr abgeschoben beck der
vorsitzender grün fordert auf es muss
mehr abgeschoben werden ich sage ja wir
haben starten
die gelten als nicht sichere
herkunftsstaaten in die nicht
abgeschoben wird ist ein zweites
beispiel wo ich dafür bin dass wir das
verändern und die grünen auf fordern mut
zu machen
georgien hat eine vorbildliche
entwicklung will sogar an die nato will
am liebsten in die europäische union wir
sagen das ist kein sicherer
herkunftsstaat geschrieben nicht ab das
gleiche für marokko algerien tunesien
ich glaube diese staaten verdienen nicht
den status dass man nicht abschieben ich
glaube wir bleiben noch gut im
themenfeld mit einer weiteren frage um
das potenzial der antworten anzureichern
von josef schreiner aus köln das ist die
nummer 11
und josef schreiner fragt ich habe den
eindruck dass sich die kleinkriminalität
weiter ausbreitet wie kann die situation
verbessert werden herr laschet
sie mögen es ja konkret naja jetzt
springe jetzt haben wir gerade beim
terrorismus das ist ja etwas was ich
viel komplizierter weil es sich lange
jahre festgesetzt hat da baut man eine
breite palette ich hab das eben
beschrieben anhand des lagebildes das
man braucht um zu wissen welche formen
von kriminalität gibt es dann müssen
unterschiedliche behörden
zusammenarbeiten werden wir uns eine
gruppe aus finanzbehörden justiz und
innenministerium die zusammenarbeiten
denn oft sind es finanzströme
schwarzgeld was investiert wird wo wir
oft gar nicht die wege des geldes wissen
und das grundprinzip ist immer wieder
das modell störe nicht
parallelgesellschaften entstehen lassen
wo man aus resignation da nicht mehr hin
schaut sondern stück für stück mit den
mechanismen die der rechtsstaat hat das
aufarbeiten so mein eindruck ist die
debatte ist in gang gekommen
in allen ländern findet das statt manche
länder sind mehr betroffen andere
bundesländer weniger aber das thema ist
heute auf der tagesordnung und ich bin
zu ich teile nicht die these dass es
schlimmer wird
ich glaube wir sind an punkt dass das
problem erkannt ist und dass jetzt die
arbeiter gegen geht ich will
ausdrücklich sagen ich liebe ja nun wie
wir alle drei in nordrhein westfalen das
was die nordrhein westfälische
landesregierung dort macht was
insbesondere der innenminister dort
macht ist vorbildhaft vorbildlich und
das allerwichtigste ist dass man diesen
clans die autos abnimmt so trivial das
klingt aber dass die vermögens-
einziehung selbst wenn man nicht
nachweisen kann dass das aus straftaten
kommt sondern die vermögens- einziehung
in diesem clans ist eines der
wirksamsten mittel um sie auszutrocknen
und da muss der rechtsstaat wirklich mit
aller konsequenz und härte vorgehen und
deswegen der schreiner ich bin auch
nicht der meinung dass das zunehmend es
ist vielleicht gefühlt das bild aber ich
habe den eindruck dass die politik
verstanden hat worum es geht und was man
tun muss und wirklich chapeau vor
herbert reul der das in deiner
landesregierung in nordrhein-westfalen
wirklich vorbildlich für deutschland
macht und geht jetzt schon so
mit den autos dran ist die vermögens-
einzigen geht das ist rechtlich geregelt
das kann man tun wenn die vermutung
besteht dass sie aus straftaten kommen
oder ungeklärte vermögensverhältnisse da
sind dann geht das und das wird gemacht
und das trifft sie an einem sehr
empfindlichen punkt wenn diese kerle
morgen zu fuß gehen müssen und aus ihren
aufgemotzten autos aussteigen müssen das
trifft die mehr als eine haftstrafe wo
sie wahrscheinlich sogar noch kriminelle
herausgekommen als hineingegangen sind
da habe ich dann noch kurz nachfragen
ist das vielleicht allgemein so dass die
das selber so eine grundsatzfrage
brauchen wir schärfere gesetze oder
brauchen wir eine bessere praxis in der
anwendung
naja also der ruf nach besseren gesetzen
der der kommt dann immer sehr schnell
ich denke wir haben gute gesetze wir
haben gerade im strafprozess bereich im
strafrecht eine menge in den letzten
jahren an veränderungen gesehen die
anwendung und die durchsetzung ist viel
entscheidender
und da muss man den polizeibeamten die
das da machen den rücken stärken und
darf sie nicht allein stehen lassen die
verdienen jede politische unterstützung
bei der verdammt schwierigen arbeit die
jeden tag da gemacht werden
dazu haben ja auch eine frage nämlich
von gerd man sude
das ist die nummer 9 liebe regie und
gerd man so gefragt mit welchen
politischen konzept wollen sie als
parteivorsitzender auf die zunehmende
gewalt gegen einsatzkräfte der polizei
reagieren und mit welchen maßnahmen
werden sie dem offensichtlichen
autoritätsverlust von polizei und
rettungskräften in teilen unserer
gesellschaft einhalt gebieten bisschen
haben es schon angesprochen herbert drin
in dem wir ohne wenn und aber hinter den
sicherheitskräften hinter der polizei
die für unseren rechtsstaat einstehen
stehen
sie stützen für vertrauen werben sie
ausstatten mit den instrumenten die sie
brauchen um ihren beruf auszuüben
das ist personal das ist die ausstattung
die sie brauchen und die öffentliche
anerkennung und übrigens auch die frage
der bezahlung die sich da immer
ausdrückt ich glaube dass das unser
interesse ist nein es ist unsere
verpflichtung dass die polizistinnen und
polizisten und andere sie haben
rettungskräfte und andere wurden zu
recht genannt dass wir sie mit der
autorität und dem vertrauen des staates
ausstatten und zwar tatsächlich ganz
konkret
mit stellen mit ausrüstung mit worten
und in angemessener bezahlung ihre idee
wie man der polizei einsatzkräften
sicherheitskräften den rücken stärken
kann
ja das stimmt was norbert röttgen
beschreibt also wir haben uns mehr
personal eingestellt die technische
ausstattung verbessert die rechtliche
möglichkeit mit einem neuen
polizeigesetz erhöht und politische
rückendeckung das ist das wichtigste
denn die gehen in schwerer einsätze zum
teil
und wenn sie danach von der politik
kritisiert werden sind sie beim nächsten
mal vielleicht nicht mehr so willens für
den rechtsstaat einzutreten und dass der
eine teil der andere aber das wundert
mich immer wieder und ich werde
wahrscheinlich in meinem leben nicht
mehr begreifen wie überhaupt jemand auf
die idee kommen kann
rettungskräfte anzugreifen ein paar
polizisten gibt vielleicht mal
konfliktlagen aber wir erleben doch
inzwischen das ganz normale freiwillige
feuerwehr sanitäter angegriffen werden
während des einsatzes
und da haben wir glaube ich inzwischen
alle parteien erkannt da geht es an die
substanz und das darf man nicht dulden
auch da gilt übrigens null toleranz der
rettungskräfte angreift begeht eine
straftat und das darf man nicht dulden
ein schönes beispiel aus der anwendung
von künstlicher intelligenz in diesem
bereich sagen die baden württembergische
landesregierung immerhin grün schwarz
hat das polizeigesetz geändert und seit
einiger zeit tragen die polizeibeamten
bei einsätzen alle body camps also
kameras es wird jeder einsatz gefilmt
sie kriegen ein unglaubliches
datenmaterial zusammen jetzt können sie
mit künstlicher intelligenz relativ
schnell dieses datenmaterial sortieren
und auf einzelne täter ausrichten
und es wird nicht mehr lange dauern dann
können sie auch vermummte täter an ihren
bewegungsprofilen erkennen und
identifizieren wir werden innerhalb der
nächsten jahre sehen wie künstliche
intelligenz im bereich der
kriminalitätsbekämpfung täter über
führungen möglich macht die wir in den
letzten jahren nicht machen konnte
vermummte täter die erkannt werden
können das wird noch eine gewisse zeit
lang dauern bis die gerichte das als
beweis sichern anerkennen aber dann
haben wir mit diesen möglichkeiten
chancen täter wirklich
festzunehmen und zu bestrafen die wir
früher nicht hatten und da muss die
politik sagen die polizei wird damit
ausgerüstet und diese technik wird
angewendet und dann wird dafür gesorgt
dass so was wie in leipzig so was wie in
stuttgart und so was wie in hamburg in
zukunft ja möglicherweise noch passiert
aber diejenigen die sich daran
beteiligen
die müssen mit einer hohen
wahrscheinlichkeit damit rechnen dass
sie erwischt werden und dass sie
bestraft werden
und das muss ich sagen finde ich eine
entwicklung die freut mich und ich sehe
vor allem dass das eine grün schwarze
landesregierung in baden württemberg
macht zeigt was offensichtlich gilt das
freut sie auch okay vielen dank herr
merz sie haben mit der künstlichen
intelligenz ein themenfeld gestreift
dass ich zum schluss für eine kurze
runde gerne noch in nehmen möchte von
hans joachim marx aus hamburg nämlich
kommt folgende frage wie stehen sie zur
cyberkriminalität und wie wollen sie sie
bekämpfen das scheint mir der ich nicht
mehr der jüngste bin herr marquis 84
eine der ganz großen aufgaben der
zukunft zu sein mit der bitte um kurze
antwort herr aldrin teilte die
beschreibung es ist eine der großen
aufgaben
es gibt täglich tägliche cyberattacken
auf privatpersonen aber vor allen dingen
auf unternehmen die erpresserisch vor
allen dingen arbeiten oder auch eine
unsicherheit stiften wollen wir haben
ein nicht angemessenes rechtliches
instrument der instrumentarium und vor
allen dingen sollte unbedingt
abgeschafft werden meine forderung dass
oder positiv formuliert was wir schaffen
müssen ist die erlaubnis des staates den
hacker-angriff auch jenseits der grenzen
des deutschen staates zu verfolgen wir
müssen an den grenzen aufhören und wenn
der hacker angriff aus dem ausland kommt
dürfen wir nicht verfolgt das teile ich
zwei bereiche wo die technologie nach
der fackel aus haben sich das 84-jährige
nach
das ist in der tat die neueste
herausforderung die täter sind auf dem
neuesten stand aller technologischen
dinge und wir müssen unsere polizei auch
so ausstatten dass cyber kriminalität
bekämpfen kann
und das gleiche brauchen wir übrigens
auch künstliche intelligenz bei
kindesmissbrauch
auch haben wir mal schildern lassen von
den beamten die diese millionen dateien
an missbrauchten kindern anschauen
müssen
das halten manche menschen nicht mehrere
tage aus das kann man auch mit neuen
technologischen mitteln inzwischen auch
mit künstlicher intelligenz leichter
machen also cyberkriminalität und diese
kriminalität braucht topausstattung dass
wir technologisch so weit sind wie die
täter sind vielleicht ich finde sind
beeindruckt dass ein 84-jähriger sich
mit diesem thema beschäftigt also großen
respekt aber wir haben es ja nicht nur
im bereich der privatwirtschaft mit
solchen angriffen zu tun sondern wir
haben staatlich organisierte
cyber-attacken gegen unsere
sicherheitssysteme gegen bundestag
bundesregierung bundeswehrkrankenhäuser
unsere gesamte infrastruktur ist
gefährdet das ist die neue form der
kriegsführung im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert und deswegen hat die
bundeswehr zu recht ein zentrum für
cyber angriffe entwickelt und wir werden
uns sehr viel stärker auf diesen bereich
konzentrieren müssen wir brauchen nicht
mehr große panzerarmee wir brauchen
technologische möglichkeiten um auch die
staatlicherseits ausgelösten angriffe
auf die integrität unserer daten systeme
besser abzuwehren und das wird eine
aufgabe sein die auch sehr viel geld
kostet ok vielen dank dann kommen wir
schon zum dritten und letzten
themenblock fast ein bisschen schade
finde ich jetzt können sie nochmal
richtig zeigen wie sie sich von ihren
mitbewerbern unterscheiden europa und
die welt dahin schauen wir jetzt sie
wissen anders als wir gehofft haben als
mancher historiker ist auch ausgerufen
hat ist die freiheitliche demokratie
nicht für alle die beste aller möglichen
staatsformen die welt sortiert sich neu
die frage ist die ihre mitglieder
beschäftigt und nicht nur die wie können
wir unsere werte im wettbewerb der
systeme überhaupt nie wie die cdu am
anspruch gerecht auch als europapartei
und wie und mit welchen allianzen können
wir europa stärken und so die welt
mitgestalten dazu haben wir zwei ein
spieler hintereinander zwei fragen
hintereinander das erste kompagnon von
philip andreas und jan
weil man aus pirmasens liebe kandidaten
für den cdu bundesvorsitz ich darf uns
kurz vorstellen wir sind philip andreas
und jan baalmann vom jungen union beim
thema sind uns beschäftigen im
wesentlichen folgende fragen zum einen
beim thema europa die cdu ist immer die
europapartei gewesen
wie können wir auch zukünftig in der
gemeinsamen außen und sicherheitspolitik
eine einheitliche stimme finden und
gerade auch im zuge zunehmender kritik
an der nato einheitlich sprechen
dank den beiden herren und dazu noch
ergänzend eine frage von marion riemer
eine kölsche und prima sagt sind sie
bereit außen und sicherheitspolitische
kompetenzen an die europäische
kommission abzugeben als ähnlich das
themenfeld damit europa mehr gewicht in
der welt gewinnt zb in der
handelspolitik
herr merz ich denke wir alle drei sind
sehr stark europäisch geprägt armin
laschet und ich war noch im
europaparlament gewesen norbert röttgen
ist in außenpolitik unterwegs also wir
werden da wahrscheinlich gar nicht so
große unterschiede haben vielleicht zwei
aspekte wir haben uns vor 30 jahren als
die deutsche einheit die europäische
einigung möglich wurde in der
einschätzung dass jetzt nur noch
demokratie und marktwirtschaft auf der
welt vorherrschen werden und ihren
siegeszug unaufhaltsam antreten alle
geirrt
es war ein großer tag wir sind heute mit
einer völlig anderen lage konfrontiert
demokratie und marktwirtschaft stehen
unter massivem druck
und wir erleben bis hin in die usa die
bilder dieser woche was da plötzlich in
demokratien geschehen kann
deswegen ist das allerwichtigste dass
wir in dieser europäischen union unsere
werte aufrecht erhalten dass wir sie
verteidigen das für demokratie und
rechtsstaat in der gesamten europäischen
union durchsetzen
das zweite ist ich bin bei der
übertragung von kompetenzen an die
europäische union skeptisch die
handelspolitik ist genannt worden von
frau riemer die handelspolitik ist
vollständig in den händen der
europäischen union die währungspolitik
auch die europäische union wird nur dann
eine zukunft haben wenn die
nationalstaaten die wesentlichen träger
dieser europäischen union bleiben ich
sehe nicht dass wir eine europäische
union
bekommen in der sozusagen unsere
identität vollständig aufgeht und wir
alle jetzt nur noch europäer sind wir
bleiben deutsche franzosen briten sind
jetzt da draußen aber wir bleiben auch
mitglieder unserer nationalen staaten
wir haben eine nationale identität und
wir haben sozusagen ein dach obendrüber
das ist europa der größte bereich wo wir
kompetenzen für die europäische union
nicht abgeben sondern gemeinsam ausüben
ist die außen und sicherheitspolitik
da bin ich auch der meinung wir müssen
mittelfristig vom prinzip der
einstimmigkeit abweichen können wir
brauchen hier auch
mehrheitsentscheidungen in der
europäischen union aber das hat folgen
bis hin in dem bereich
sicherheitspolitik streitkräfte einsatz
von streitkräften das ist kein triviales
thema dass wir zeit brauchen
und weil es mit 27 auf einen tag und auf
einen schlag nicht geht bin ich der
meinung bis an die grenzen dessen was
die verträge zu lassen sollten wir auch
bilateral mit 23 45 staaten beginnen
können und sagen wir empfangen an andere
können folgen damit wir wenigstens
handlungsfähig bleiben denn das was auf
der welt passiert schauen sie nach
amerika schauen sie nach asien schauen
sie nach china braucht eine europäische
antwort und ich sage mal auf den ganz
einfachen nenner gebracht worden wir
weiter kreisklasse spielen jeder für
sich alleine oder wollen wir champions
league spielen auf der welt eine rolle
spielen ich möchte dass europa auf der
welt gespielt
ok vielen dank jetzt bin ich gespannt ob
ihre stirn in falten legt herr laschet
sie haben neulich gesagt europa mehr
europa ist in unserem nationalen
interesse ist ein widerspruch
nein nicht unbedingt die frage ist ja
wie die entscheidungsfindung stattfindet
also identität hin kann man ja schwer
abgebenden identitäten sind ja da und
man hat eine identität die frage ist nur
wie wir handlungsfähig wir haben 1992 in
den maastrichter vertrag hereingespielt
hineingeschrieben wir machen eine
gemeinsame europäische außen- und
sicherheitspolitik wunderbarer text und
dann brach der krieg auf dem balkan aus
und wir waren nicht in der lage zu
handeln es hat erst der amerikaner
bedurft die an den krieg auf
europäischen boden dann am ende beendet
haben und aus dieser erfahrung hat
europa dann gesagt ja jetzt brauchen wir
auch eine europäische sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik hat ende der 90er
jahre begonnen
da gab es auf und ab man hat
fortschritte gemacht aber wir sind noch
nicht so an
unfähig dass wir das europäisch schaffen
könnte jetzt teile ich das was völlig
märz gesagt hat dass das auch bilateral
vorbereitet werden muss können sich
direkt an der 27 vielleicht schaffen wir
haben im aachener vertrag den
deutsch-französischen vertrag sehr
konkrete möglichkeit sind wie
deutschland und frankreich da vorangeht
offen für alle anderen und ich glaube da
müssen wir damit wir weiter gehen
das wird irgendwann auch zu mehr
mehrheitsentscheidungen führen und ich
würde das beginnen vielleicht nicht bei
den aller kompliziertesten themen
sondern bei denen die nahe liegen die
auch uns in europa betreffen
ich war mal den europäischen parlaments
zuständig für die nachbarschaftspolitik
das heißt unser interesse ist rund um
das mittelmeer möglichst demokratien und
staaten zu haben die eng mit europa
verbunden sind algerien marokko tunesien
libyen merken wir schon den konfliktfall
da ist russland und die türkei tätig da
muss europa seine rolle spielen die
bundeskanzlerin hatte hier zu einer
konferenz in berlin
da finde ich da kann man zusammen zeigen
dass es unser interesse der libanon
derzeit in einem schweren unglück
prozess das einzige land mit christen
schiiten und sunniten
der französische präsident sich sehr
engagiert da kann deutschland auch
unterstützend mit tätig sein auf
diplomatischen feld und bei dem thema
finden wir vielleicht auch ein konsens
unter den 27
kompliziert wird bei militäreinsätzen
und da gilt nach unserer verfassung
immer noch das entscheidungsrecht des
bundestages wenn deutsche soldaten
irgendwo in einsätze geschickt werden
das kann man auch so schnell nicht
auflösen aber mehr brauchen wir okay
danke schön
wir haben ein dilemma wenn europa sich
selbst behaupten will in dieser neuen
zeit und lage großmächte politik
auflösung von ordnungen dann brauchen
wir eine europäische handlungsfähigkeit
auch nach außen wir brauchen erstmal den
zusammenhalt europas der es auch bedroht
und wir müssen nach außen handeln
handeln können aber wir haben wir sind
nicht einig und auch gemeinsame
außenpolitik setzt einigkeit voraus und
dich wird auch in den nächsten fünf
jahren keine einigkeit
in der europäischen union für eine
außenpolitik der 27 mitgliedstaaten
geben und mein ansatz ist so wie du
eigentlich schon angedeutet hatte ich
glaube wir müssen etwas zuwege bringen
sonst geht europa unter das werden wir
zerrieben und mein vorschlag ist das ist
ein pragmatischer vorschlag dass wir mit
einer gruppe beginnen der willigen der
fähigen nicht abschließend offen für
alle aber wir müssen beginnen einige
eine außenpolitische agenda aufzusetzen
und sie abzuarbeiten
das sollte kein west projekt sein
frankreich deutschland sollten natürlich
dabei sein
wir müssen ringen dass polen dabei ist
damit das ost west zusammenhält wir
sollten ich bin dafür ein angebot an die
briten machen auf diesem gebiet auf
staaten auf der basis der
mitgliedstaatlichen politik zusammen zu
wirken
eine perspektive für das europäisch
britische verhältnisse und dann fangen
wir an zwei drei themen zu definieren
die von gemeinsamen interesse sind und
da vereinbaren wir nur eins ein veto
gibt es nicht sondern wir machen politik
und diese europäische stimme und die
fähigkeit die müssen wir dann auch
transatlantisch einbringen
denn ohne die usa so schwierig ihre
innere lage jetzt nochmals schwieriger
trauriger geworden ist dieses bündnis
ist unverzichtbar unersetzbar und darum
müssen wir inhalt einbringen zum
beispiel auf diese weise bevor wir
transatlantisch werden und auch andere
regionen der welt noch mit einbeziehen
würde ich gern noch eine frage
übermitteln von dirk insel die in europa
spielt und zwar fragt jetzt hensel wie
wollen sie die rechtsstaatlichkeit in
der eu sicherstellen welchen kurs werden
sie gegen polen und ungarn einschlagen
muss dass ein kurs gegen polen und
ungarn sein heller schwierige frage
wir haben es geschafft ganz erstmal in
der pandemie nicht geschafft direkt
europäisch zu denken
der nationale reflex war wieder da virus
ist da grenzen schließen
wir haben die belgisch niederländische
grenze bei uns immer offen gehalten und
mit den anderen kooperiert also da war
der nationale reflex da dann haben wir
danach nord und süd zusammengehalten
durch die gemeinsamen anleihen weil wir
wissen auch wir deutschen werden nicht
wieder stark wenn der süden im
binnenmarkt schwach ist
deshalb war der merkel makro vorschlag
richtig und jetzt die ost west frage und
die wird oft vergessen und ich finde die
rechtsstaats prinzipien die jetzt auch
in der neuen haushaltsordnung für die
nächsten sechs jahre festgeschrieben
sind ein guter kompromiss
das europäische parlament hat sich mehr
gewünscht aber es ist ein guter
kompromiss weil wir es nur auf dem weg
hin kriegen wir können ja nicht einfach
sagen die polen und ungarn sind uns
jetzt egal
sie sind teil der europäischen union wir
müssen alles tun dass sie auf den weg
der rechtsstaatlichkeit zurückkehren
aber wir müssen sie auch an uns binden
einfach sanktionen raus geht nicht und
das ist ein mühsamer dialog prozess auf
allen ebenen außenpolitik diplomatisch
wirtschaftlich kulturell
wissenschaftlich sie sind kern europas
norbert röttgen hat das gerade
beschrieben für die verteidigungspolitik
auch für anderes aber es gibt auch
grenzen wo dann der europäische
gerichtshof europäische institutionen
sagen müssen wenn ihr das und das macht
muss das notfalls auch finanzielle
konsequenzen haben aber trotzdem sie
nicht aufgeben dran bleiben und auch auf
die zivilgesellschaft in den ländern
setzen
ok zuckerbrot und peitsche ihr blick so
norbert röttgen dem volk jetzt
ja das ist eine es eine grundlegende
infragestellung der europäischen union
die europäische union die idee europas
historisch politisch philosophische
rechtlich ist die idee des rechts das
ist dass das sind wir und wir sind nicht
wie herr auf einmal gesagt hat die
liberale demokratie sondern europa ist
die verkörperung der liberalen
demokratie und der herrschaft des rechts
darum ist das ein grundlegender angriff
auf die identität und die steht nicht
zur disposition
das sind wir nebenbei sind auch die
mitgliedstaaten mit einzubeziehen in der
korruption herrscht wenn korruption in
einem staat herrscht dann ist es auch
nicht rechtsstaat das ist das gegenteil
von rechtsstaat
die sind die müssen wir auch wahrnehmen
ich bin dafür dass alle instrumente
ausgeschöpft werden rechtliche
gerichtliche und dass der ogh die fälle
auch annimmt und dagegen entscheidet ich
bin zweiter dafür dass wir den blick aus
weiter von polen ungarn auf die eben
schon genannten staaten in denen
korruption herrscht und ich bin drittens
dafür dass die dass die europäische
union die mitgliedstaaten und die
gemeinschafts organe die fälle wirklich
benennt wir dürfen es nicht verschweigen
öffentlichkeit ist immer noch der beste
anwalt für diejenigen denen das recht im
eigenen land versagt wird und da muss
müssen die anderen staaten und die
organe laut seien deutlich seien nicht
taktieren es ist eine grundfrage das
recht ist die grundfrage des die zukunft
und des überlebens der europäischen
union
ok danke herr merz das darf ich noch
ergänzen das ist ja so eine sohn
dauerbrenner auch in der außenpolitik
wie konziliant ist man also diese
schwierige abwägung zwischen gute
kommunikationswege erhalten aber auch
mal klare kante zeigen ja das ist ja das
geheimnis des erfolgs von europa dass
wir bereit sind auch kompromisse
miteinander zu machen dass wir auch
bereit sind aufeinander zuzugehen
nur man muss polen und ungarn in der
jetzigen situation eben auch klar sagen
wenn ihr 2004 waren sie beigetreten sind
so gewesen wäre wie ihr heute seid
hättet ihr die eintritts voraussetzung
in die europäische union nicht erfüllt
so nicht wir haben uns verändert sondern
diese länder haben sich im laufe der
zeit leider verändert wir haben hier
zwischen ost und westeuropa muss man
etwas grob abzugrenzen einen
grundsatzkonflikt über die vorstellungen
von demokratie und diese diskussion
müssen wir führen und ich muss sagen ich
bin ausgesprochen dankbar dafür dass es
der bundeskanzlerin gelungen ist zum
schluss der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft im letzten jahr
wenigstens einen mechanismus als ersatz
gerade gesagt in die haushaltsverfahren
einzubringen wo man diesen ländern
mittel kürzen kann und dann der
europäische gerichtshof die frage prüft
ob das mit rechtsstaatlichen erwägungen
zulässig ist oder nicht also wir haben
einen mechanismus der hätte schäfer sein
können aber wir haben einen mechanismus
und das ist für sommer sagen europa es
ist mühsam man braucht geduld man muss
miteinander reden aber das ziel diesen
kontinent zusammenzuhalten rechtfertigt
ist allemal
das klingt so als wäre der weg richtig
ich halte diesen weg unter den gegebenen
umständen für richtig er hätte besser
sein können er hätte schöner sein können
er hätte schneller sein können aber wir
müssen mit denen arbeiten die da sind
und das sind nun mal die gewählten
regierungen in polen ungarn auch in
anderen staaten osteuropas übrigens dass
die korruption hat norbert röttgen
angesprochen bulgarien rumänien sind
länder die weit von den standards
entfernt sind die wir in europa für
normal halten müssten also wir müssen
reden
ok danke schön reden müssen wir auch mit
china das schließt ganz schön an
inhaltlich und da hat herr professor
doktor reza asghari aus braunschweig
folgende frage
china wird demnächst die größte
volkswirtschaft der welt darstellen was
in hongkong geschieht zeigt was der
machtzuwachs chinas für die westlichen
demokratien bedeutet china übernimmt
systematisch mehr als anteile deutsche
high tech startups china hängt uns im
bereich der cup haben sie eine
china-strategie und wenn ja was sind die
akzente dieser strategie herr röttgen ja
ich würde dir die frage mit ja
beantworten ich glaube sehr konkrete
vorstellungen über eine china-strategie
die auch die beschreibung teilt und
trotzdem schlage ich übrigens kein
feindseliges verhältnis gegenüber china
für china ist eine realität aber china
setzt
hat sich für endlich jene hat sich
verändert china unterschiedlichen ping
ist nicht mehr dass china das unter den
vorgängen da war die innerstaatliche
repression haben kann ist nicht ist ein
teil davon wo auch einen vertrag
gebrochen wird ist systematisch und
technologisch das machtmonopol von china
hat es seit mai auszeit nicht gegeben
und china macht eine aggressive
außenpolitik und setzt wirtschaft und
die abhängigkeit von lieferketten von
staaten ein um vergeltungs und
abschreckungspolitik zu machen
hongkong ist als beispiel genannt worden
gegenüber diesen dieser realität china
dass ich für die größte internationale
außenpolitische herausforderung des
westens für absehbare zeit halte ist die
erste antwort einigkeit den einigkeit
ist stärker man kann auch sagen stärke
ist die antwort und stärke wird nur
entstehen durch einigkeit also brauchen
wir eine europäische china strategie und
das heißt auch dass deutschland wenn wir
über china reden nicht mehr nur sagen
kann china ist für uns ein der größte
ein großer markt ein bedeutender markt
und das war's
das ist so das bleibt aber china ist
viel mehr geworden das ist genannt
worden und ich plädiere auch für eine
transatlantische china-strategie die
jetzt unter der neuen administration
wieder möglich wird eine kooperative
eine konstruktive aber einer aus der
position der stärke
und zwar eine doppelte der moralischen
stärke die route in unseren werten der
menschenwürde der liberalität des rechts
und eine technologische stärke
wir können in china nicht vorwerfen dass
es technologisch sich entwickelt man
kann manche praktiken vorwerfen dass
technologie raubs und so weiter aber die
entscheidende frage ist unsere
technologie stärke das wird zunehmend
die entscheidende frage auch in diesem
system wettbewerb werden haben wir
eigene vor allen dingen technologische
stärke
da müssen wir mehr tun und das wieder
europäisch teils auch transatlantisch zu
beantworten also die china strategie die
die bundesregierung jetzt wenige tage
vor silvester für die europäische union
ja noch einmal markiert hat ist eine
europäische das ist richtig denn wir
brauchen erstmal diese europäische
antwort
in der tat bleibt china handelspartner
ein großer markt aber mit eklatanten
menschenrechtsverletzungen gegenüber den
uiguren gegenüber der lage in hongkong
die man benennen muss das aber das
kunststück von außenpolitik steht ja
nicht darin nur mit ländern mit denen
mit belgien und luxemburg zusammen zu
arbeiten sondern auch mit ländern die
ein anderes menschen und
gesellschaftsbild haben lösungen zu
finden um konflikte zu verhindern und
die beschreibung dass china das auf
allen ebenen tut übrigens derzeit mit
dem impfstoff china ist jetzt schon
dabei seinen impfstoff teilen afrikas
anzubieten um auf diese weise wieder die
länder an sich zu binden
daran merkt man die die seidenstraße das
modell quer über die welt ist ein
infrastrukturprojekt was am ende ein
fluss in den ländern nimmt und diesen
wettbewerb müssen wir aufnehmen
technologisch stimme ich zu
künstliche intelligenz beispielsweise
wenn uns das nicht passt was die machen
die menschen damit quasi bis in den
letzten winkel des lebens zu beobachten
und wenn wir wollen dass sich unser
gesellschaftsbild durchsetzt müssen wir
technologisch in der lage zu sein sein
genauso gut zu sein und das kann kein
nationalstaat alleine dazu brauchen wir
27 mitgliedstaaten die ihre kompetenzen
bündeln und diesen wettbewerb aufnehmen
und ab dem zwanzigsten januar vielleicht
sogar mit der perspektive dass die usa
mitmachen präsident trump hat manchmal
den menschen reden gesagt ja das ist ja
alles schlecht was da in china nordkorea
und deutschland passiert der hat nicht
mehr in bündnis kategorien gedacht und
der neue präsident spricht von den like
nein die demokratie ein ähnliches
menschenbild haben wir und jenseits des
atlantiks und wenn wir das bündeln
dann haben wir gute chancen diesen kampf
zu gewinnen ok vielen dank herr merz wir
haben in den letzten jahren nach meiner
einschätzung die macht und den
machtwillen chinas in europa massiv
unterschätzt
ich bin in den letzten jahren einige
male in china gewesen einige male in
hongkong gewesen
die entwicklung dort haben wir nicht
genügend beobachtet und wir haben leider
zu wenige die sich auch analytisch damit
beschäftigen was zum beispiel dieses
seitenstraßen projekt bedeutet es ist
nicht nur ein wirtschaftliches projekt
es ist ein imperiales politisches
projekt der chinesischen staatsführung
und wenn man einmal die beschlüsse des
neunzehnten parteitages der kurdischen
partei von china aus dem oktober 2017
noch mal in erinnerung ruft was da
beschlossen worden ist was jinping
seitdem für einen machtzuwachs hat und
wie er damit umgeht dann ist dies aus
meiner sicht eine ganz ernsthafte
bedrohung unserer freiheit aber auch
eine ganz ernsthafte bedrohung des
freien welthandels und auch eine
ernsthafte bedrohung der multilateralen
politischen ordnung die auf regeln und
verträgen beruht china hält sich in der
regel nur dann an die verträge
denn es im eigenen interesse liegt sie
brechen sie vollkommen rücksichtslos
wenn es im eigenen interesse liegt sie
zu brechen
ich finde wir sollten sehr viel härter
sein
wir müssen auch die abhängigkeit der
deutschen wirtschaft vom chinesischen
markt sukzessive reduzieren die werden
sowieso auf dauer dort keinen erfolg
haben weil sie irgendwann nicht mehr
gebraucht werden und wir sollten und da
bin ich mit armin laschet völlig einig
die chance des regierungswechsels in
washington nutzen um mit der neuen
amerikanischen administration eine
transatlantische strategie entwickeln
wie wir mit china umgehen insbesondere
in allen internationalen institutionen
wo die amerikaner leider mit trump eine
position nach der anderen auch physisch
persönlich geräumt haben und in jede
offene position chinesische amtsträger
mandatsträger hineingegangen sind da
haben wir ein echtes problem und das
müssen wir ziemlich schnell lösen wenn
wir da zum gleichgewicht beitragen
wollen dass auf dieser welt auch im 21
jahrhundert fortbesteht
ok vielen dank damit haben sie noch
nicht beigetragen zum gleichgewicht der
welt aber zur meinungsbildung bei
unseren zuschauerinnen und zuschauern
ganz herzlichen dank dass sie diese drei
runden alle engagiert bestritten haben
ja zum schluss liebe kandidaten haben
sie jetzt noch mal die gelegenheit ein
ausrufezeichen zu setzen hinter all dem
was sie heute gesagt habe noch einmal zu
unterstreichen was sie besonders bewegt
und ein bisschen ist das dann vielleicht
schon ein parteitags gefühl wo sie ja in
einer woche auch stehen werden und ein
statement halten werden und zum
parteitag noch folgende info
cdu-parteitag punkt.de liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer da finden
sie noch mehr dazu am freitag geht's um
18 uhr los und am samstag um 9 und ich
glaube mittag so fair ist dann die wahl
was ja sehr spannend wird also lieber
herr röttgen sie sind der erste fürs
abschluss statement wir haben einen
counter und der läuft 120 sekunden
sobald sie soweit sind und das pult
steht dort zu ihrer rechten das ist
jetzt anders als da gehen sie jetzt hin
und bezaubern uns mit ihrem ersten
schluss statement
die fangen ein handy kamera kamera
dieser wie und es geht los wenn sie
müssen also ich möchte mich gerne an sie
wenden
liebe parteifreundinnen und
parteifreunde und natürlich an alle
interessierten die an den bildschirmen
sind es ist toll dass sie dabei sind das
ist ganz wichtig weil es ausdrückt dass
wir lebendig sind und dass wir interesse
finden ich wünsche ihnen allen an den
bildschirmen ein glückliches ein
gesundes ein erfolgreiches neues jahr
wünschen ihnen dass es gut wird für sich
und in ihren familien
wir haben heute diskutiert wir haben und
ich habe zehn monate über zehn monate
diskutiert sehr viel diskutiert mehr als
eigentlich je zuvor und als digitaler
wurde noch mehr ganz viele diskussion
mit der basis die ich geführt habe und
ich möchte ihnen ganz kurz natürlich ein
bisschen berichten was das mit mir
gemacht hat
es hat natürlich zur veränderung geführt
weil ich habe ja nicht nur geredet ich
habe auch zugeführt und darum hat es
auch geschafft das was mein angebot an
die cdu ist als cdu vorsitzende
ich möchte ihnen sagen ich bin kein
lager ich stehe für alle und ich glaube
auch dass diejenigen die mich nicht
wählen werden wenn ich gewählt werde mit
mir leben können und mich akzeptieren
ich stehe für die moderne mitte
alle bis auf die und linkspartei wollen
ja mitte sein aber es ist die aufgabe
die mitte auszufüllen sie mit inhalten
zu füllen das was die modernen
fragestellungen sind das müssen wir sein
und dann füllen wir den platz und den
anspruch moderne mitte zu sein
auch aus dafür stehe ich das schönste
was mir gelungen ist in diesen zehn
monaten ist wie viele menschen ich
aktiviert habe aktivieren konnte dass
sie dabei sind
dass ich sie für die cdu gewinnen konnte
in oben aus urbanen milieus junge leute
ausdrücklich solche die nicht schon
immer cdu wählen und nicht unter allen
umständen
ich stehe für ein klares modernisierungs
profil die cdu muss weiblicher jünger
digitaler werden wir müssen die fragen
angeht die unsere zeit bietet
klimaschutz digitalen sicherheit
ich möchte dass sie alle mitmachen bei
diesem projekt dazu lade ich sie ein
ich möchte mitmachen in welcher funktion
auch immer werde ich dienen machen sie
auch mit sie werden gebraucht
dankeschön norbert röttgen zum hygiene
konzept gehört auch dass die tische kurz
desinfiziert werden aber das geht ganz
schnell herr laschet und sie können sich
gern schon auf den weg machen und sobald
sie dastehen und fertig sind geht ihr
kot darunter bitte
liebe delegierte liebe freundinnen und
freunde liebe zuschauer die nicht
parteimitglieder sind
ich habe mich nicht zehn monate in
diesem wettbewerb begeben können weil
wir über monate von der pandemie
gefesselt waren und entscheidungen
fällen mussten für viele millionen
menschen zum lebensschutz und unser land
gut durch diese krise zu bringen
und deshalb ist auch das was wir da am
16 januar machen eine entscheidung der
cdu in einer außergewöhnlich
historischen lage und wir werden daran
gemessen ob wir durch gutes
regierungshandeln den menschen zeigen
dass wir verantwortung übernehmen können
dass wir schwierige entscheidungen
fällen können und den hohen zuspruch den
wir derzeit bei der bevölkerung haben
haben wir auch deshalb weil man uns
zutraut der bundeskanzlerin zutraut der
bundesregierung zutraut den
ministerpräsident zutraut dieses land
gut durch die krise zu bringen
wir müssen uns jetzt schon vorbereiten
das wird die aufgabe des neuen
bundesvorstand seien für die zeit nach
der pandemie die wirtschaftlichen folgen
die haushalts folgen die folgen für
unser gesundheitssystem wir müssen unser
land modernisieren hinein in die
zwanziger jahre und wir haben alle
defizite in diesen monaten erlebt von
der schule über die ausstattung der
verwaltungen und vieles andere mehr
und sie werden fragen was bringen sie
dann mit ich bringe mit
regierungserfahrung leitung eines großen
landes ausgleich zwischen
unterschiedlichen interessen und was
vielleicht auch nicht ganz schädlich ist
für einen cdu vorsitzenden auch schon
mal eine wahl gewonnen zu haben denn die
wahlen im nächsten jahr sind
entscheidend für die zukunft unseres
landes ich will dass die cdu auch ab
september regierungsverantwortung für
deutschland hat dafür kämpfe ich und
dazu bin ich bereit
[Musik]
danke schön herr laschet
herr merz sind wir gespannt wozu sie
bereit sind ja meine damen und herren
sie haben vielleicht zwei sendungen
dieser art mit bekommen heute abend
stehen wir kurz vor dem abschluss der
bewerbung um das amt des cdu
parteivorsitzenden
wir stehen am beginn eines spannenden
wichtigen superwahljahres 2021 in
deutschland und am ende dieses jahres ja
schon in gut acht monaten wird
entschieden wer dieses land in die in
das dritte jahrzehnt des schon begonnen
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts führt wir
stehen vor großen aufgaben aber wir
stehen auch auf einem festen fundament
dessen was in den letzten jahren
erreicht wurde
aber jetzt geht es darum nach vorn zu
schauen einen aufbruch zu wagen
erneuerung zu ermöglichen in deutschland
und in der europäischen union
ich habe konkrete vorschläge
unterbreitet was wir tun können um
dieses land erfolgreich weiterzuführen
dazu zählt aus meiner sicht insbesondere
eine ökologische erneuerung der sozialen
marktwirtschaft dazu zählt für mich dass
wir einen neuen generationenvertrag in
deutschland mit der jungen generation
abschließen um deren zukunftschancen
auch wirklich so zu ermöglichen dass sie
die gleichen chancen haben wie die
generation ihrer eltern
und dazu zählt dass wir die europapartei
der bundesrepublik deutschland bleiben
wir haben heute abend darüber
ausführlich diskutiert diesen anspruch
volkspartei der mitte zu bleiben den
möchte ich mit einem team einlösen mein
team wird der gewählte bundesvorstand
der cdu deutschlands seien ab der
nächsten woche endgültig dann
festgestellt in der übernächsten woche
und ich möchte die gelegenheit auch
nutzen dem generalsekretär der cdu
deutschlands im irak und auch dem ganzen
team hier im adenauer-haus herzlich zu
danken für die exzellente vorbereitung
dessen was wir bisher machen konnten und
ich mir ganz sicher wir werden einen
richtig guten parteitag in der nächsten
woche haben den ersten vollständigen
digitalen parteitag einer partei in
deutschland herzlichen dank
dankeschön friedrich merz in allen
dreien vielen dank für diese schluss
tables und ganz herzlichen dank dass sie
insgesamt sechs themenfelder am schluss
gibt es doch noch ran für alle dass sie
insgesamt sechs themenfelder mit uns
beackert an das ist toll
in liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
danke ich sehr für ihr interesse ist
bleibt ja sehr spannend wir sind alle
denke ich sehr daran interessiert wenn
die 1001 delegierten dann nächste woche
zum neuen parteichef der cdu gehören
alle drei das haben wir heute gemerkt
setzen auf sieg aber alle drei haben
auch versprochen gute verlierer zu sein
wir wissen mit blick woanders sind das
ist nicht selbstverständlich also es
bleibt spannend meine damen und herren
bleiben sie dran und bleiben sie gesund
und wir sind zurück in bonn im studio
das war eine veranstaltung der cdu auch
die moderatorin war von der cdu gestellt
worden
das muss man vielleicht noch einmal
sagen dass man keine sendung die von
phoenix gestartet worden ist
ja wer ist denn eigentlich der sieger
ich habe die möglichkeit mit andrea
römmele professor andrea hämmerle
politikwissenschaftlerin zu sprechen die
ich sehr herzlich begrüße schon guten
abend herr westerwelle ganz einfache
frage wir haben jetzt anderthalb stunden
erlebt wir haben schluss stellten uns
noch einmal gehört wer ist aus ihrer
sicht derjenige der sich am besten
profilieren konnte ich denke das war ein
klarer punktsieg für armin laschet der
seine ganze regierungserfahrung und
kompetenz ausgespielt hat er hat bei
jedem thema bei jeder anfrage
die an ihn gerichtet wurde ganz klar
gesagt wie er es schon umgesetzt hat was
seine erfahrungen im regierungsgeschäft
sind also ganz klare ganz klarer
punktsieg für armin laschet dem er
vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen auf die
einzelnen themen ein das war ja so natur
dori sowie auch in der ersten runde eine
tour doris die vereinigen um drei große
themen kreis sind nämlich einmal um die
umwelt klimapolitik um die innere
sicherheit und dann
die europapolitik diskutiert hat und die
internationale politik das war so ein
bisschen ausgerichtet an den
schwerpunkten der kandidaten haben diese
kandidaten in ihren schwerpunkten sich
noch einmal profilieren können
also was mich am meisten überrascht hat
muss ich ehrlich sagen ist dass
friedrich merz in seinem thema nämlich
sicherheit innere sicherheit doch wenig
punkten konnte in diesem thema haben
herrn fand ich persönlich herr laschet
und herrn röttgen überzeugende hatte in
der ersten hälfte der der debatte das
hat man auch gemerkt so ein bisschen
anlaufschwierigkeiten er musste sich
erst warm reden konnte dann aber in der
zweiten hälfte der debatte als es um
europa und vor allem auch um
internationales ging seine
themenkompetenz hier ganz ausspielen und
herr laschet hat sich in jedem thema
eigentlich sehr sicher und auch sehr
staatstragend präsentiert also hier auch
nochmal die ganze kompetenz eines
ministerpräsidenten ausgespielt und so
hat er sich auch präsentiert also musste
ja sehr genau zuhören das haben sie erst
recht als professorin für
politikwissenschaften natürlich getan
man musste sehr genau zuhören weil wir
haben ja hier drei kandidaten einer
partei
es sind ja teilweise nutzen gewesen
diese und diese unterschieden haben wenn
sie das mal aus der position der
delegierten sehen wir haben ja hier
keine öffentliche wahl sondern wir haben
ja am 16 januar eine wahl durch die
delegierten
wenn sie sich in die delegierten
hineinversetzen wer von den drei
kandidaten hat denn am ehesten so den
eindruck vermittelt das ist jemand für
die zukunft der partei
also am visionärsten muss ich sagen
auch inhaltlich war sicherlich norbert
röttgen
röttgen hat eine moderne eine nach vorne
gewandte
cdu präsentiert er hat auch das fand ich
sehr interessant in seinem abschluss
statement ganz klar gemacht dass er ein
kandidat wäre auf hinter dem sich viele
in dem sich vielleicht auch alle
vereinen können dass er keinem lager
zugehört der herr laschet hat ganz klar
ein weiter so präsentiert ich habe
regierungserfahrung
letztendlich wäre eine fortsetzung einer
eine also wäre er die fortsetzung einer
einer merkel-regierung und herr merz hat
wie es eigentlich auch zu erwarten war
ich empfand ihn als am polarisierendsten
er hat ganz klar seine klientel
angesprochen aber ist darüber auch nicht
hinausgegangen
so auch ein thema ganz zu anfang nehmen
da ging es um klimaschutz und die frage
zum beispiel der landwirtschaft und der
frage wie weit kann man landwirtschaft
und flächenverbrauch auf der einen
versöhnen mit der tatsache dass wir
immer mehr wohnungen und immer mehr
wohnfläche brauchen da merkte man da
waren alle drei nicht so wirklich
konzeptionell unterwegs also man hatte
so den eindruck dieses klima thema da
sagte man ja man muss versöhnen auf der
einen seite die klimapolitik aber auf
der anderen seite muss ja auch den
menschen wohnraum geboten werden
war das vielleicht ein bisschen zu
oberflächlich um tatsächlich in dieser
sehr wichtigen frage die wir ja nach der
pandemie wieder als ganz wichtige frage
diskutieren werden
wirklich zu behandeln und inhaltlich zu
bilden bestätigen
insgesamt muss man sagen er war das ein
sehr herausforderndes format also keiner
der kandidaten konnte sich darauf
vorbereiten und es war auch ganz klar
dass fragen kommen werden in denen man
nicht ganz so sattelfest ist und es geht
eben in einem solchen format auch darum
solche fragen elegant zu beantworten und
natürlich ist da
amtsinhaber im vorteil weil er eben
tagein tagaus im politischen geschäft
unterwegs ist und sich hier eventuell
auch in unter unterschiedliche kontexte
zusammenbringen kann
aber wie gesagt dass man in manchen
fragen nicht so sattelfest ist ist teil
des formates und da müssen die
kandidaten eben auch zeigen wie sie mit
so einer situation umgehen
es geht eben nicht nur um die
politischen statements und die
politischen eigenschaften der kandidaten
sondern eben auch um die sogenannten
unpolitischen eigenschaften und dazu
gehört eben wie man mit solchen
situationen auch umgeht
professor war meine ganz herzlichen dank
für eine einschätzung direkt nach dieser
runde
wir gehen jetzt direkt nach berlin zur
erhard scherfer der nicht um diese runde
herum saß sondern der draußen warten
musste jetzt ist er glaube ich drin wenn
ich es eben richtig verstanden habe und
er hat die drei kandidaten an seiner
seite zumindest hoffe ich das noch sind
nicht alle da aber einer der reihe nach
reicht ja auch erst mal unbesiegt in der
tat in einen nebenraum inzwischen vom
foyer hier im konrad adenauer haus und
draußen ist es jetzt noch ein bisschen
arg ungemütlich und wäre es auch für
mein gast begrüßen ministerpräsidenten
von nordrhein westfalen einen der drei
kandidaten für den cdu parteivorsitz
armin laschet schön dass sie sich noch
mal die zeit nehmen auch für uns wir
haben ja die ganze veranstaltung auch
komplett übertragen jetzt noch ein
bisschen journalistische nach erwartung
von unserer seite her dass etwas haben
sie gelernt wie mit vergangenen wochen
nun monaten darüber was die mitglieder
der cdu von ihrem neuen
parteivorsitzenden erwarten
da sind die erwartungen sehr sehr
unterschiedlich wir haben zwei
landesverbände die knapp vor
landtagswahlen stehen und die wollen
natürlich rückenwind haben den rheinland
pfalz und baden württemberg andere
fragen mehr wie sieht das im hinblick
auf die bundestagswahl auf ganz andere
normale mitglieder sagen ja wie wird das
dann mit der parteiarbeit können wir da
nicht mehr beteiligt werden können wir
nicht die formate digital diskutieren
auch in der zukunft beibehalten also die
wünsche sind quer durch und es war
beleben das alles zu hören und ab 16
jahre war um zu sein
welche wünsche würden sie dann am
ehesten umsetzen wollen oder halten sie
für zwingend dass sie umgesetzt werden
hat die wahlen gewinnen ist immer
wichtig das ist dem bund vor aber dass
konkrete jetzt in der diskussion in der
partei genau bedeutet die digitalen
möglichkeiten zu diskutieren gibt es
eigentlich schon lange
wir nutzen sie erst seit der pandemie
und ich will dass wir bei den fachthemen
jemand der für sich für außenpolitik
interessiert und in konstanz lebt dass
der mit einem in schleswig-holstein
diskutieren kann dass wir diese
möglichkeiten bieten den sachverstand
der in der partei da ist einzubeziehen
auch für unsere entscheidung und das ist
ambitiös das erfordert zeit aber ich
glaube auch ministerpräsident auch
bundesminister auch die kanzlerin auch
andere müssen sich diesen diskussionen
immer wieder stellen denn sie bereichern
dem stern habe sich dieser tage gesagt
jeder gute ministerpräsident kann auch
in deutschland regieren das war in
dieser frage konkret auf markus söder
bezogen aber sie haben dann in der
folgenden antwort auch gesagt auch sie
trauen sich es auch zu warum sind sie
ein guter ministerpräsident und warum
während sie dann anschließend auch ein
guter kanzler war gut bei der
kanzlerkandidatur sind wir ja noch nicht
wir sind jetzt bei der frage wer wird
parteivorsitzende der cdu kritisiere
warum während sie ein guter
parteivorsitzender
da glaube ich dass es wichtig ist
zusammenzuführen christlich soziale
liberale konservative das sind die
wurzeln der cdu
menschen zusammenzubringen und zum
ausgleich zu führen das habe ich in
meinem ganzen politischen leben immer
gemacht in nordrhein-westfalen sitzen
all diese unterschiedlichen richtungen
mit am kabinettstisch entscheidend mit
und diese vielfalt brauchen werden der
bundes partei und deshalb trete ich ja
auch im team mit jens spahn an
wir waren nicht immer einer meinung aber
beides ist cdu und dieser teamgedanke
ist mir persönlich sehr wichtig jetzt
plant ist ein prima stichwort die frage
hat sich sowieso noch vorbereitet es gab
heute meldungen jens spahn sind ihre die
möglichkeiten möglicherweise viel zur
kanzlerkandidatur auch anzutreten
möglicherweise geht es gebe sogar
überlegungen innerhalb der cdu sie dazu
zu bewegen
vom zurückzuziehen was die kandidatur
für den parteivorsitz
angeht was ist dran an diesen
geschichten was können sie dazu sagen
oder sind sie alle aus der luft
gegriffen was bei ihm dran ist müssen
sie ihn fragen er hat mir versichert
dass da nichts dran ist und meine
kandidatur ist vorgeschlagen wurden vom
landesverband nordrhein westfalen
einstimmig damals im februar wir stehen
dazu ich habe eine idee wie die cdu
geführt werden soll
und jens spahn teilt diese idee so dass
an dem versuch jemanden abzubringen
nichts dran ist das kann ich bestätigen
aber er kann natürlich noch unterstützer
finden bis zum parteitag und trotzdem
noch kandidieren ich so dass wenn
manchmal ist es ja möglich ich glaube ja
natürlich ist das möglich ich glaube
nicht dass er das tut ich glaube seinem
wort das er im team steht und insofern
mache ich mir da keine sorgen
das haben sie vorher ist er auf die
frage warum so möglicherweise auch ein
guter kanzler sein könnten das steht
noch nicht zur diskussion stimmt steht
doch nicht im moment nicht weil sie erst
mal gewählt werden müssten zum
parteivorsitz dann müsste mit markus
söder verhandelt werden wer den
kanzlerkandidat wird und auch dann
müssen sie anschließend noch mal gewählt
werden nichtsdestotrotz was ist die
dringlichste aufgabe in diesem land die
einen kanzler anpacken müssen vor allem
auch im hinblick auf die gefährdung der
demokratie in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten und vor allem auch im hinblick
beispielsweise auf das was jetzt gerade
in washington passiert ist also in bezug
auf das was in washington passiert würde
ich nur sagen ich wünsche mit diesem
bundestagswahlkampf hart in der sache
aber ohne persönlichen angriffe werden
merken was es bedeutet wenn ein land so
aggressiv einen wahlkampf führt dass es
danach ganz schwer ist das land wieder
zu versöhnen
wir haben in deutschland eine andere
tradition und gerade in diesem wahljahr
wird das wichtig sein wie wir demokraten
miteinander umgehen das ist im hinblick
auf die wahl wichtig und danach ist es
wichtig die themen die nach der pandemie
anstehen kompetenz zu bearbeiten
die wirtschaftlichen probleme die dann
da sein werden die haushaltsprobleme
wieder wachstum zu ermöglichen
die ohnehin bestehenden umweltprobleme
die klimaschutzziele erreichen und
trotzdem industrieland zu bleiben also
aufgaben gibt es genug
ich habe mit jens spahn ideen vorgelegt
für einen modernisierungsschub zehnt in
den zwanzigern und das ist das was ich
mir dann auch für die bundestagswahl
vornehmen habe ich noch ne kurze frage
dazu weil ich mir das auch oft nun
notiert hatte weil sie die ganze breite
der gesellschaft soll sich in der cdu
widerspiegeln also die ganze breite
werte glaube ich auch die cdu nicht
hinkriegen da sehen sie eine
einheitspartei das wollen sich ja auch
noch wo ist in der usa in der größe nach
und nach haben wir 25 prozent frauen
haben bei den mitgliedern fehlt was wenn
der altersdurchschnitt 60 ist fehlt was
nämlich junge leute frauen wir haben im
land 25 prozent menschen mit einer
einwanderungsgeschichte die findet sich
in der cdu nur sehr vereinzelt also die
breite der gesellschaft ansprechen
das ist schon unser ziel darauf kann man
sich einlassen herr laschet vielen dank
dass sie nach dieser an der tap
stündigen grunde noch mal auch noch mal
zu uns gekommen sind vielen dank sie
dürfen diesen platz verlassen wir machen
nämlich meine damen und herren
fliegenden wechsel wenn ich das richtig
gesehen habe ist nämlich der nächste
gesprächspartner auch schon da und da
steht da auch schon norbert röttgen auch
in vielen dank dass ich jetzt noch mal
gekommen sind nach einem der länge eines
ganzen fußballspiels da vorne
wie viel sind sie den cdu-vorsitz heute
nach eigenem empfinden näher gekommen
das ist ja eine diskussion gewesen ich
glaube die war gut die hat auch akzent
unterschiede gebracht und das finde ich
auch wichtig und jetzt ist es an den
delegierten zu bewerten zu entscheiden
welche cdu möchte sie ich glaube mein
profil ist klar was ich für die partei
möchte und die delegierten werden eine
autonome entscheidung der frage gehen in
die richtung wie gut haben sie sich
gefühlt in der runde wir haben sieben
sind in welchen eindruck haben sie wie
sie ihre positionen vertreten haben
ich glaube ich konnte zu allen diesen
drei themen meine positionen darlegen
dass klimapolitik von überragender
bedeutung ist und dass wir als cdu sie
eben mit der wirtschaftskompetenz
verbinden müssen ist meine zentrale
aussage dass wir europa zusammenhalten
und handlungsfähigkeit handlungsfähig
machen das ist meine arbeit seit jahren
als vorsitzender des auswärtigen
ausschusses und das sicherheit ganz
zentral ist innere sicherheit äußere
sicherheit sozialer sicherheit und dass
man die innere sicherheit nicht ohne die
äußeren fragen internationalen fragen
islamistische terrorismus bei
antworten kann das konnte ich gut
rüberbringen rechtsextremismus haben sie
jetzt nicht erwähnt darüber haben wir
heute ja nicht gesprochen aber dass der
rechner bei innere sicherheit aber auch
mal durchaus aber die fragen gingen
jahre konkret über islamistische
terrorismus und darum habe ich darauf
auch geantwortet der rechtsextremismus
ist einer der großen neben dem
islamistischen terrorismus und den
gefährdungen die weitere größte
innenpolitische bedrohung unseres landes
ich habe dann wird eben auch schon
gefragt
sie haben hier einen teil der beantworte
möglicherweise schon weggenommen weil
sich in ihrem schlussstatement
aufgegriffen haben und die frage ist was
haben sie gelernt über ihre partei in
den vergangenen wochen im zusammenhang
mit der kandidatur für den parteivorsitz
ich habe wirklich viel gelernt weil ich
viel diskutiert habe und das bedürfnis
und den willen der partei aktiv zu sein
die partei wieder zu erleben als ein ort
der diskussion der entscheidung wo all
diese fragen die auch ängste machen die
die menschen sehen auch eine rolle
spielen um unsere antworten zu geben aus
unseren werten heraus moderne fragen zu
beantworten wir haben potenzial wir
haben willen und bereitschaft wenn der
input zu groß gewesen ist aus ihrer
partei von den mitgliedern wo gibt es
punkte wo gibt es positionen wo sie
sagen ja da denke ich noch mal drüber
nach da muss ich meine möglicherweise
auch noch mal ein bisschen nachjustieren
das ist in denen in den einzelnen
bereichen das habe ich ja gesagt dass
man sich vorgetragen habe
das ist auch produkte die möglicherweise
daran im moment ja auch keine kritik
wollte sagen ich habe genau er das
vorgetragen was ich was auch das
ergebnis der diskussion ist zum beispiel
meine aussage ich bin kein lager
das resultiert auch daraus dass die dass
die mitglieder sagen wir wollen die
einheit in dieser partei und wir wollen
auch wenn wir nicht den kandidaten
zugestimmt haben hinter ihm stehen
können und ich glaube ich werde diese
partei nicht polarisieren oder spalten
sondern zusammenführen das ist zum
beispiel ein solches ergebnis die
kandidaten das kandidatenteam laschet
sparen hat dieser tage ein papier
vorgelegt ist doch kurz angesprochen
wurden heisst impulse 21 ein zehn punkte
programm kommt von ihnen noch etwas
ähnliches bis zum parteitag ich bin ja
mit einem
sechs punkte programm gestartet ich bin
gestartet weil ich gesagt habe
es geht nicht um die frage wer wird was
das ist auch eine wichtige frage aber
was wird aus der cdu und ich bin
programmatisch gestartet und habe immer
wieder zu unterschiedlichen fragen auch
konkret und ausführlich position bezogen
ich habe zum beispiel die initiative aus
formuliert dass wir auf die entscheidung
des amerikanischen neuen präsidenten
beiden mit john kerry ein klima
außenbeauftragten zu benennen also ein
signal klima außenpolitik zu machen dass
wir das annehmen sollten auch einen
solchen beauftragten haben sollten mit
kabinettsrang und auf europäischer ebene
um eine neue chance im transatlantischen
verhältnis zu gewinnen oder die
digitalisierung an digitalisierungs
backt weil wir zu rückgängen stichwort
klare positionen sie haben zu beginn
dieser kandidatur gesagt es ist
eigentlich automatisch dass sie auch
kanzlerkandidat werden müssten sie haben
dass zwischenzeitlich ein bisschen
abgeschwächt glaube ich in dieser form
wie ist die position ihre position heute
einmal klar und deutlich
da muss ich sie 40 ein bisschen
jedenfalls deutlich sagen ich vertrete
in dieser frage exakt von beginn an seit
einem dreiviertel jahr die gleiche
position weil sie nämlich aus
überzeugung ist das selbstverständnis
und das habe ich im februar gesagt das
selbstverständnis der cdu ist das ihr
vorsitzender
das amt des kanzlers können und wollen
muss sonst sollte man ihn nicht zum cdu
cdu vorsitzenden wählen
und zweitens weil auch diese
bundestagswahl noch mal wichtiger ist
als jede bundestagswahl
weil so viel auf dem spiel steht geht es
darum dass wir die best aufstellung
finden und das ist dann die
verantwortung der beiden
parteivorsitzenden von markus söder und
mir wenn ich gewählt werde diese best
aufstellung zu beraten und vorzuschlagen
letztlich sind auch noch mal an sie auch
von im hinblick auf das was vor zwei
tagen in washington passiert ist auch
bei uns werden institutionen wie
parlament politiker auch die justiz
zunimmt in frage gestellt und nicht mehr
ernst genommen und ihre leute halten
sich auch nicht an
an viele regeln ist es kurz angeklungen
bei ein zwei beispielen wo würden sie am
ehesten ansätzen um
das zu korrigieren sie haben völlig
recht wir haben in usa war es der
amtierende gewählte präsident der
angestachelt und angestiftet hat das
haben wir nicht aber wir haben auch
hassrede wir haben auch agitation wir
haben auch das verächtlich machen der
institutionen des staates und wir müssen
auch wegen dieser mahnung aus den usa
noch entschiedener entgegentreten die
demokraten zusammen ohne jede
taktiererei und wir müssen dort ansetzen
wo der boden bereitet wird aus dem dann
eines tages gewalt kommt in großer
klarheit und entschiedenheit müssen die
demokraten das tun dann haben sie ganz
herzlichen dank mich dass wir in dieser
runde noch mal zu uns gekommen sind wenn
ihr damit er nicht gucke kurz zur seite
und ich sehe dass auch der dritte und
letzte in der runde das ist jetzt
einfach auch schon an seinem platz ist
immerhin ist der längste von 1
insofern herzliche herzlich willkommen
auch ihnen herr merz schön dass sie sich
auch noch mal die zeit nehmen im sommer
haben sie sich große chancen
ausgerechnet auf den parteivorsitz im
herbst haben sie festgestellt dass
beachtliche teile des sogenannten partei
establishments gegen sie arbeiten wie
sehen sie ihre chancen heute unverändert
über das ganze jahr die chancen sind gut
wo ausgezählt wird am nächsten samstag
und entschieden ist es erst am
übernächsten freitag also heute in zwei
wochen
also sie haben sich glaube ich auch
schon mal zuversichtlich
nein ich bin unverändert sehr
zuversichtlich aber ich habe auch großen
respekt vor dem votum der delegierten
und das nehme ich nicht vorweg ich
kämpfe um jede stimme aber die
delegierten entscheiden und was passiert
wenn es nicht klappt ich konzentriere
mich voll darauf dass es klappt ich habe
unverändert gute chancen
es läuft gut ich kriege viel zustimmung
aus der partei auch aus der bevölkerung
ich habe in allen abstimmungen die auf
kreisebene stattgefunden haben in der
partei und das waren viele immer die
nummer eins besetzt also die basis der
cdu will einen parteivorsitzenden vor
durch märz und daraus die weise sind
aber nicht die delegierten deswegen
kämpfe ich um jede einzelne stimme der
delegierten aber die delegierten sind
die vertreter der pass ist eine frage
war auch vor dem hintergrund dass auf
der
auf den internetseiten der cdu steht
dass alle drei kandidaten erklärt haben
dass wenn sie nicht wer also die zwei
zumindest von denen die nicht zum
parteivorsitzenden gewählt werden werden
so erkennen und sichtbar sich weiter
einbringen aber vor dem hintergrund dass
ich ja schon vor 2018 war es auch
kandidiert haben danach was ein bisschen
stiller um sie was sie über mein angebot
hat damals gestanden und steht heute ich
bin bereit auch für diese partei zu
arbeiten auch für dieses land zu
arbeiten und jetzt konzentriere ich mich
darauf den parteivorsitz zu erreichen am
januar 2021 weil vereine es wichtig ist
die selbe frage die ich den anderen
beiden gestellt habe auch an sie was
haben sie gelernt über ihre partei in
den vergangenen monaten sie sind ja auch
schon seit sommer mit dabei sind viel
gereist auch im sommer so weit ich weiß
und sie werden wahrscheinlich ja nicht
nur zu partei oder zu untergliederungen
gefahren sein
die märz fans sind wie beispielsweise
die junge union
ich habe in der tat die parteien noch
mal ganz intensiv kennengelernt ich bin
dankbar für zwei ganz besondere
erfahrungen des erste ist wir haben eine
tolle junge union und tolle junge
mitglieder in der cdu auch junge frauen
die sich unglaublich engagieren und die
etwas bewegen möchten
und ich bin viel in ostdeutschland
unterwegs gewesen nicht mag diesen teil
deutschlands besonders ich bin dort gern
und ich finde dort auch eine cdu vor die
in vielerlei hinsicht anders denkt
anders sozialisiert ist als die alte
westdeutsche cdu aber gerade deswegen
bin ich gern dort und ich bekomme dort
auch viel unterstützung also diese
beiden teile haben mir noch einmal den
blick geweitet und auch die ja vielfalt
dieser partei noch einmal deutlich
gemacht
jetzt kommt ausgerechnet heute die
meldung dass die frauen-union sich
positiv geäußert hat bis die
kandidaturen von norbert röttgen angeht
und die von armin laschet
aber sie haben sich jetzt gerade nicht
so besonders hervorgehoben und wie
würden sie da sagen die arbeit der
vergangenen woche war in der hinsicht
ein bisschen vertan nein das war bei
allem respekt das war der vorstand der
frauenunion naja ich habe
ich bin mit verlaub ich bin der einzige
der drei kandidaten der eine
internetseite sogar zu seinen gunsten
sid ich habe sie gar nicht selber
gemacht sondern sie ist von einer jungen
landtagskandidatin aus friedrichshafen
schon vor einem dreiviertel jahr
aufgebaut worden wir frauen für
friedrich merz und dort gibt es eine
große zahl von jungen frauen auch
älteren die für mich ein treten in der
partei und ich habe beim letzten mal hat
sich für den deutschen bundestag
kandidiert habe 57,7 prozent der stimmen
bekommen
das wahlergebnis hätte ich nicht
bekommen wenn mich nicht auch die
mehrheit der frauen gewählt also dieses
negativ teile ich ausdrücklich nicht ich
habe viel unterstützung auch bei den
frauen
vielleicht habe ich jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen geärgert weil sie doch keine
generalsekretär in aufgeboten haben ja
darüber verhandelt sich ernsthaft weise
ernsthaft niemand ärgern wir sind jetzt
acht monate und wenige tage vor der
nächsten bundestagswahl paul ziemlich
macht seinen job im adenauer-haus
wirklich hervorragend das ganze was wir
hier auch erleben ist seine arbeit er
hat das hier ermöglicht er bereitet den
parteitag vor mit ihm gehen wir dann
auch in die bundestagswahl und wir haben
alle drei gesagt wir wollen ihn als
generalsekretär behalten das ist eine
auszeichnung für ihn aber das ist
natürlich auch eine rationale
entscheidung jetzt in den vorsitzenden
aus zurück sind und den generalsekretär
das wäre heller waren sind das machen
wir nicht auch wenn sie nochmal und aus
gründen der vergleichbarkeit zwei tage
nach dem sturm aufs kapital welche
lehren welche konsequenzen sind nötig
auch bei uns ich kann nur immer wieder
sagen die respektlosigkeit vor der
demokratie die respektlosigkeit vor den
demokratischen institutionen und die
respektlosigkeit vor den personen nimmt
diesen verlauf und endet in dem was wir
vorgestern in washington gesehen haben
deswegen bitte ja zu politischen streit
und zu unterschiedlichen auffassungen
die brauchen wir in der demokratie aber
bitte auch in anständiger form in
vernünftigem umgang und in jederzeitigen
respekt auch vor dem politischen gegner
friedrich merz herzlichen danke ihnen
aber denke dass sieben nach dieser runde
noch mal zu uns gekommen sind und das
war es jetzt aus dem
konrad-adenauer-haus hier in berlin ich
gebe zurück zu michael krons in bonn und
da gibt sich hat auch das eine oder
andere nach zu besprechen und zu
analysieren
mit andrea römmele
ja er hat schon ganz herzlichen dank
professor andreas menne habe ich immer
noch sozusagen in der leitung die erste
frage ist die hat das was er hat scharfe
jetzt noch mal sehr pointiert
nachgefragt hat ihren eindruck verändert
nein eigentlich nicht
also herr laschet ist hat sich ganz gut
positioniert was die frage jens spahn
anbelangt ellmann herr spahn hat in den
umfragewerten in den letzten monaten
enorm gepunktet es gab ja jetzt auch in
dem politischen berlin das gerücht dass
ersparen sich eventuell auch
positioniert ich denke das hat er sehr
gut umschifft und auch nochmal auf jens
spahn sword verwiesen und dass man als
team antrete
die große kanzlerkandidatenfrage kam
natürlich wieder auf herr röttgen finde
ich hat das auch sehr elegant gelöst
dass er auch sich als teamplayer gezeigt
hat und gesagt hat ja natürlich ist es
so dass dem parteivorsitzenden
letztendlich das erste zugriffsrecht wie
es so schön heißt zusteht aber dass man
das auch im team sehen muss und dass man
letztendlich die für die lösungen stehen
muss die partei am weitesten voran
bringt beziehungsweise der partei am
meisten stimmen mit einbringt und herr
merz hat sich so präsentiert wie er sich
auch in der debatte präsentiert hat sehr
siegessicher sehr selbstbewusst spricht
hier mit natürlich auch sehr seien seine
seine basis an
also insofern hat sich das fortgesetzt
was wir auch in der debatte gesehen
haben
sie haben eben gesagt eigentlich liegen
für sie quasi die beiden personen
röttgen und laschet vorne an dem laschet
hat sehr stark nochmal erstens mal
darauf abgehoben dass er eine große
politische erfahrung nicht nur hat
sondern
ministerpräsident ist eine wahl gewonnen
hat norbert röttgen hat sehr pragmatisch
gesagt ich möchte dass ich weiß was ich
will und ich werde dieses programm auch
verfolgen wenn ich gewählt werde
das war sagen wir mal gar nicht so weit
auseinander
ist es vielleicht so wir müssen ja jetzt
sozusagen ein bisschen spekulieren dass
die delegierten sagen das ist auch eine
schwierige auswahl denn wir haben hier
jemanden der hat eine wahl geworden der
ist ministerpräsident der hat ein hohes
ansehen auf der anderen seite müssen wir
auch mal schauen wie die zukunft der
partei aussieht und da ist vielleicht
norbert röttgen der richtige ja klar
also die ich denke dass merz lager ist
klar eingeschworen
da stehen die da stehen die truppen wenn
man das so sagen darf und herr röttgen
wird herr laschet stimmen abgreifen bzw
herr laschet wird herrn röttgen stimmen
abgreifen hier wird in einem
hier wird im gleichen lager gefischt und
das wird ganz interessant seien auch was
die nächste woche noch passiert also der
wahlkampf er hinter den kulissen aber
auch der mediale wahlkampf wird nächste
woche in die letzte runde gehen
und das wird sehr interessant sein zu
beobachten was wir jetzt natürlich auch
aufgrund der verhältnisse in den usa
sehen ist dass herr röttgen aufgrund
seiner americas expertise natürlich
nachgefragte ist als gesprächspartner
als interviewpartner also hier auch
nochmal eine zusätzliche bühne hat das
wird nächste woche noch ganz interessant
sein zu beobachten aber es ist ganz klar
im ersten wahlgang wird es darum gehen
wie viele stimmen nimmt herr röttgen aus
dem laschet lager und wer tritt dann im
zweiten wahlgang gegen friedrich merz an
ich gehe davon aus dass friedrich merz
den zweiten wahlgang erreichen wird und
dass das rennen letztendlich für den
zweiten wahlgang zwischen herrn laschet
und her
röttgen laufen setzen weil meine ganz
herzlichen dank für ihre expertise danke
nach hammam an sie herzlich gerne meine
damen und herren und all das fassen wir
natürlich auch noch mal in der tag
zusammen um 23 uhr und wir schauen das
ist absolut notwendig in diesen tagen
noch einmal nach washington auf die
reaktionen auf das was in den letzten
beiden tagen dort passiert ist vor allen
dingen vorgestern sagen sie um 23 uhr
wieder dabei bis gleich
[Musik]